wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn how even procrastinators can get
rich how to set up income streams that
pay you each month what you can learn
from Steve Jobs and why only a few
people achieve success get ready to
transform your financial future and
learn the secrets of real wealth
building
enjoy hi there and welcome to episode 8
of wealth breakthroughs I'm Patrick
gentempo how many streams of income do
you think the average millionaire has
three or maybe four those would be good
guesses but the answer is seven the
average millionaire has seven different
streams of of income and you can quickly
learn how to easily set up your own
multiple income stream system that pays
you cash month after month Zack shite of
St Paul research is going to show you
how today as we kick off episode 8
here's
[Music]
Zach Zack thanks so much for taking the
time to sit and have this conversation
today yeah I'm excited to be here you
have this interesting background in
history with the things you've done so
let let's start with the you know your
your past and how you got to doing what
you're doing now yeah so I I grew up in
Atlanta Georgia in a suburb of Atlanta
I'm one of 11 kids and um yeah we we we
had a lot of good questions along the
way uh but my my mom decided to
homeschool us um she was a very
organized person still is a very
organized person she she uh made sure
that we focused on all the things that
we needed to know uh growing up and she
really focused the the interesting thing
is she didn't focus on the the test
itself but preparing us for life um and
that's something I I admire about her
yeah exactly and so we had a lot of uh
we we had a lot of planning that we had
to do ourselves to make sure that we
covered all the bases for uh the
curriculum that we were supposed to
cover um it was neat I actually got to
teach my younger brothers and sisters
how to read uh because that was part of
the the whole curriculum was not just
learning things ourselves but uh
learning them well enough to be able to
teach others which actually came in
handy farther down the road as I as I
moved along in my career and so forth
and then you went to college what' you
study yeah I went to Lee University a
small school in Cleveland Tennessee
studied business uh graduated from there
uh packed it into three and a half years
uh so that I could marry my high school
sweetheart so the deal was get done as
as soon as you can get married and I was
excited to start a family and we we sure
enough did well so you were one of 11
how many kids do you have I have seven
kids my parents think we have a good
start so we're talking about like wealth
breakthroughs and wealth accumulation is
a having a bunch of kids like the wealth
evaporation exactly no I I joke around I
have to have 7x uh income 7x income so
because I've got so many different
streams that it goes out so we have to
make sure we have lots of different
income streams to to cover all the bases
there well now if you lived on a farm it
might be a good thing you put them to
work right exactly they haven't figured
that out
yet so then uh did you and I think you
got a a postgrad degree too yeah so um
when I graduated from Lee I came back we
we moved back to Atlanta my hometown um
I started working for a bank sunrust
bank and um while I was doing that I
worked at night or I went to school at
night uh and got my MBA from Georgia
State ni so working hard during the day
putting in the hours getting that done
at night but I wanted to knock that out
as soon as I could so that U my kids
hopefully would wouldn't be able to
remember their dad being out late uh
studying all of that um by the time they
got old enough that we'd be able to
spend more time together and um you it's
important to me I really I love my
family and I want to do the best that I
can for them did you have a a career
Vision at this point uh or you know what
got you moving into your next stages
yeah I I always loved the idea of the
financial markets um being able to think
with your head and to to make your money
work for you so the idea of being able
to invest in other companies uh being
able to build multiple streams of income
uh that was always something in the back
of my mind um when I worked at sunrust
uh that wasn't necessarily the direct
career path uh towards being in in the
financial markets uh but I was always
keeping my eyes open and trying to
network as much as I could and I kind of
got lucky uh about a year and a half
after I started working at sunrust uh
one of the guys that I went to church
with with actually was his company was
invested in a hedge fun fund and he
introduced me to the guy that ran that
hedge fund and I got to interview there
and it was really sort of a courtesy
more than anything um but after that
interview um the portfolio manager's
assistant resigned and uh just happened
to be the week after and so I was still
fresh on his mind and he called me back
up and I went back in and had a little
bit more of a formal talk with them and
wound up getting the job as a research
assistant and that was kind of uh what
got me into the financial markets and uh
understanding more about what goes on uh
with stocks and bonds and options and
all the different uh opportunities that
people have did you like the research
side the work that they put you on I did
I loved it um just being able to sit
down and and look through a a company's
balance sheet and income statement I'm a
numbers guy so like all the logic goes
together and it makes sense but then the
markets trade not just on logic but also
on human psychology and there's fear and
there's greed and there's all of these
different forces that push uh prices
back and forth and so as really unique
um situation where you where you have to
be able to think through things very
critically but then you also have to be
able to anticipate how other people
might view things and it it it's just
it's very intriguing and there's
something different every day so you're
not sitting there doing the same
spreadsheets over and over um every day
there's something different to analyze
and I love that it was it was unique and
exciting and U great spot to be so what
ended up happening so uh you started as
an assistant analyst I guess and end up
uh as far as did you move forward at
that at that job I did I did so I
started there and as an assistant I was
researching a lot of stocks and the
portfolio manager was pulling the
trigger on which stocks we were going to
buy or sell uh and about a year into it
uh I got the opportunity to manage a
small part of one of the funds that we
ran so the company had three different
uh hedge funds which are basically like
mutual funds uh for the Rich and Famous
um and why are they only for the Rich
and Famous well the the way that they're
set up is that they're only available to
accredited investors which means that
you have to have a million dollars or
very high income to even be able to
invest in these funds and the reason is
because the SEC doesn't uh monitor those
funds the same way that they would
monitor a regular mutual fund so they
kind of fly under the radar as far as
regulation is concerned and the SEC says
we only want these kind of funds to be
available to the big boys the people who
can do their own due diligence right um
and so yeah we couldn't help like I
couldn't even invest in the funds myself
uh when I started there uh because I you
know I wasn't an accredited investor um
so it was it was a little bit different
we weren't necessarily helping uh the
the normal investors that that I'm able
to talk uh talk to today um but it was
very exciting because I got to rub
shoulders with a lot of people who had
done quite well in business um our
clients were doctors lawyers uh small
business owners uh oil Titans uh
sometimes there was there was an ays to
the Coca-Cola Fortune we lived in
Atlanta so there was a lot of Coca-Cola
money right there um so it was it was
really exciting to be able to see and
talk with people who had been very
successful in their careers and we were
in charge of managing their money but
there was so much that I could learn
from them as far as the the business
that they had built so you ended up uh
actually managing I guess then and you
know picking your own trades and you
doing that whole part of the work uh
what was that like for you did did it
succeed did it have troubles what
happened yeah so yes yes and yes and
yes um so when I first started managing
money for the hedge fund uh Bill gave me
a small piece of one of the funds and it
was it was a separate account but it was
part of the the whole fund and I got to
track my performance and he basically
said you can do anything that you want
to with this money but we know how the
fund is supposed to invest and we know
that we are our clients are risk averse
and you know they've already built their
wealth and so it's our job to help grow
that wealth in a very responsible manner
right um and so I had some limits on you
know how much I was allowed to lose uh
and how aggressive I could be and he
told me if if your account is down 15%
at any point in time um we're going to
bench you we're going to pull the plug
and you're not going to be able to
manage money anymore and you're going to
have to sit on the sidelines and so that
actually wound up happening to me um and
it was uh the it was along alongside the
whole N9 11 uh when when the towers came
down and the market was uh was offline
for a while and I had a position that uh
that went down and it was it was really
frustrating uh obviously there was so
much else going on in in the world at
that time uh and and my you know little
account didn't didn't matter on on that
scheme but it was also a learning
experience for me to to just understand
that markets can can act in ways that
you don't expect and you always have to
have your guard up and you always have
to protect the wealth that you've or
that your client have worked so hard to
to build and so I did wind up getting
benched after that uh that event and
spent six months going back to my
research analyst position and just
looking at stocks and having to give all
of my research to somebody else and let
them make money off of off of those uh
ideas so that was frustrating and yet I
think it was one of the best things that
could have happened to me in my career
at that time I was I was young I was
managing a small amount of money it
wasn't enough that it it really moved
the needle or made a different for our
clients but it it definitely mattered to
me and it uh it taught me a good lesson
just about um risk management uh being
being very thoughtful about what the
different outcomes could be and um yeah
I'm a stronger investor because of it
were there cuz that was an extraordinary
circumstance obviously you know 911 did
other people who were working at your
hedge fund also uh get below the 15% or
no were they were they somehow hedged
against something like that yes yes so
they had already uh there there were
actually only three people managing
money at the fund at that point in time
cuz we were we were a small shop we
managed a lot of money uh but we were a
small shop in terms of the number of
people that were actually investing um
and Bill my boss and Mentor at the time
he was he was so good at being able to
protect and to to think about always
having uh like you said things hedged so
if you have a position that's that's
going to make money if this happens he
would have something backed up so that
if if that didn't work it would cause
something else to do well and that was
the whole idea behind the hedge fund is
is building different sides of of income
so that no matter what happened on one
side you would have something else that
that could do quite well so that was
frustrating but moving on from there I I
was able to after the six months was up
I came off probation if that's what you
want to call it and um and during that
six months Bill kind of took me into his
office many times and we talked through
different situations and different
opportunities that he was was looking at
and from that point I was able to to
grow the money that I managed um and
also was able to take on more
responsibility um Bill actually asked me
to manage the individual accounts of the
customers that we had so many of the
customers would put money into the funds
but many of the other customers would
have their own accounts and we would be
in charge of just investing in their own
accounts and that uh that was a really
unique opportunity because I could call
up um Joe or Bob or whoever these these
people that were our clients uh and and
say this is what I did in your account
um and this is where we have created
income they would come to our annual
meetings and I would sit next to them
and have dinner with them and talk about
the different positions that I had built
in their account um and so it was a it
was an exciting time to be able to uh
that was that was the the successful
time being able to to see how my hard
work was paying off for them and um and
to you know to to be able to have those
conversations and explain how that
worked so uh did you move on I guess
from the hedge funds where'd you go from
there yeah so uh the uh life kind of
changed uh in in 2008 for me and it it
really wasn't directly related to the
financial crisis it was more uh to how
life was changing for our family um in
2008 October 21st I'll never forget the
day um we were expecting Twins and uh we
went into the hospital my wife was uh
set to be induced uh Autumn and Emma
were were being born and couldn't wait
to to meet them um but I found myself in
the delivery room you know the financial
crisis is going on we have to balance
our positions there are a lot of changes
that we needed to make to make sure that
we're protecting our our customers and I
I'm standing there in the delivery room
and I've got my cell phone and I'm
barking orders into the in into the the
trading floor the New York Stock
Exchange sell sell sell at the same time
I'm standing there with my wife's right
there in the bed I'm saying push push
push and
it was a cathartic moment where I I
realized this is this is not the life
that I expected I love financial markets
I love what I'm doing here but I'm I'm
not even here fully here for the birth
of my children and it was just kind of a
wakeup call to me that that uh while
this was a great opportunity it's not
where I wanted to spend the rest of my
career and so from that point um I wound
up uh resigning my position at uh at the
hedge fund and um um joining uh St Paul
research at that or one of the the
predecessors to St Paul research um I I
wound up resigning my my job at pedmont
and uh moving over to write investment
newsletters where I was able to share
many of the ideas that we had talked
about many of the wealth building
strategies that we had at the hedge fund
and and share them with the people that
I really cared about with uh the people
that actually needed that type of income
instead of just the accredited investors
and that you know was a was a new
chapter in in my life in my career
you're a fan I think or you advocate for
multiple streams of income yes so what
does that mean to you to have multiple
streams of income what does that look
like sure well so I've got seven kids so
I've got to have 7x my income right um
and I think that's important for many
people that um there are there are so
many different opportunities to generate
income in America today uh but most
people don't really think about all of
the different opportunities that we have
most people go to a job and they say
that's that's my income uh or maybe
begin to to move up the ladder of
different ways of generating income but
there there's so many different um
possibilities so we know that a savings
account is a great way to you know you
put money aside and uh you're able to
generate some income you know a small
yield off of that savings account uh but
it's it's pretty low on the ladder
especially you know when you go through
periods with low interest rates where
where you're getting next to nothing off
of savings account and you can move up
from there you know there there are uh
treasury bonds or other Bond portfolios
that you can invest in that are very
safe those are savings accounts and
obviously it's it's difficult to make
much money in the savings account right
now with just you know 20 years of low
interest rates and it's not it's not the
strongest area if you need something
that you can get your hands on quickly
uh that works but but very low income
and I suspect you don't put any of your
money in savings accounts uh not not
anything that I don't need in the next
month or so okay yeah uh but then beyond
that there's there's bonds and bonds can
give you a little bit more yield um
especially uh if you look into corporate
bonds uh where companies are literally
legally required to pay you an income uh
because that's the the terms of the the
bonds that you're able to buy uh and
moving on from there there are a lot of
dividend just on bonds real quick so
with interest rates low it's still
probably the yield on bonds is would you
say not that great right now or well
you'd be surprised it depends on what
kind of company you look at and many
people when they they hear bonds they
think of Treasury bonds which are
government bonds and yes you're
absolutely right the yield on government
bonds is very low right but then if you
continue to move up the ladder the yield
on corporate bonds and these are bonds
that a company owes you money they're
basically borrowing money from the
general public uh and when you buy a
bond you're lending a company money
right and depending on that company's
credit worthiness depending on their
business depending on what sector
they're in you may get a higher yield
for that and those are some of the
things that we look at we all the
details on those companies and what kind
ofs you can get but many of those are
actually uh substantial where you can
get a few a few percentage points even
even higher depending on um how they're
set up and the risk there is that the
company defaults it is yep and that's
why you need research that's why you
need research and and one of the things
that I actually love about bonds is that
the income that you get is guaranteed
they're required to pay that um by law
if if they're able to and if they're not
able to uh typically the bond holder
actually receives whatever is left for
the company so if the company goes
bankrupt and they can't pay their debts
but they have real estate or they have
factories or they have a brand that they
can sell to another company all of the
proceeds from those assets would go to
the bond holders so there's a a level of
safety there that's not there for some
of the other um income streams got it um
and then moving up from there you we
have dividend stocks and if you invest
in in a company it means that you own a
piece of the company so you can own a
piece of a of an iconic American company
and as that company continues to make
money um they're able to pay a portion
of that to you as an owner one of the
things that I love about dividend stocks
is that there's multiple ways that you
can actually make money there's a
dividend which is your income and that
I'm all about income right uh but on top
of that as the company grows uh the
price for the stock can go up as well so
you can make money that gets paid to you
on a quarterly basis and you can make
money because the stock that you own
becomes worth more over time so those
are some of the the more traditional
ways of generating income and beyond
that there there are additional ways uh
some some strategies that we used at the
hedge fund there were actually some
option strategies that a lot of people
don't realize uh they they're they're
not aware of them because it takes one
or two or three steps to actually put
this type of a position together uh but
these are ways that you can generate
income that's very very reliable and
that's much more lucrative on a
percentage basis uh than you could get
in many of the traditional ways and
those are things that you know Bill
would sit me down and actually walk me
through step by step on how these
particular trades set up and there the
that's the exact same thing that I do
with my readers is we we are able to
give a stepbystep instruction of here's
how you put this position together
here's the income that you can receive
and here's what you can expect from this
position moving forward forward so it's
almost like uh I'm repeating the the
one-on-one sessions that I had with Bill
uh being able to sit down and and show
other people those income
strategies and then beyond that you know
those are all done in the financial
markets uh but beyond that there's so
many streams of income uh that you can
make outside of the market you know we
talk about real estate um a lot of
people have made an amazing amount of
wealth uh from Real Estate either buying
real estate and renting out either room
or renting out entire houses or or some
you know corporate uh real estate as
well um as there are other strategies
where you can where you don't even have
to invest in real estate where you can
be in involved in the managing of other
people's real estate and make sure that
uh things get taken care of and there's
less investment but maybe a little bit
of time and uh a little bit of care for
somebody else's real estate that still
pays income along the way we actually
wrote uh the big book of income um
which is uh an assortment of 47
different workfree ways that you can
generate income and and this these
different ways run the gamut from uh
investment opportunities like we talked
about earlier to uh being able to be in
in in real estate type management to
even things as simple as going for a
walk in the park or watching a sports
game or you know there there's so many
creative ways that you can actually
generate income from doing the same
things that you would normally do just
doing them in a way that uh that
somebody's willing to pay you for for
being in that spot how does somebody pay
me to walk in the park well what if you
what if you took your neighbor's dog for
a walk uh you could get paid for that or
maybe not your neighbors there's
actually a service out there that you
can list yourself and say hey I'm one of
the people in your neighborhood who
loves uh to to be able to take a walk in
the park with your dog and I'll make
sure your dog has a good time and there
are people in your neighborhood who
would be willing to pay for that and I
mean what a what an enjoyable afternoon
and at the same time you're you're
generating income to be able to go out
to dinner with a loved one that evening
I mean those are some just that's just
one of the creative ways that um that
we've been able to to put in that big
book of income and actually we're adding
extra chapters to it on a monthly basis
so you know there there's more than 47
at this point we've been able to to
build lots of different kind of
off-market creative ways to to generate
that extra income and is that really
kind of your um I guess you know the
thing that drives you is is is finding
ways to generate income for non accredit
in investors you know you more average
uh income people and uh watching them
build wealth because how do you go from
those um those bits of income you know
lots of small bits uh at what point do
you does that start to translate into
real wealth for that person yeah I'm I'm
a big proponent of multiple streams of
income uh because I do think that is how
you generate real real wealth and you
look at um not just the traditional ways
but uh but many of the the off-market
ways that we've talked about um I am
really thankful to have the opportunity
to work with like you say non accredit
investors people like my parents uh who
are in the retirement stage of life and
they want to spend time with uh with the
people that matter to them uh a lot of
times I talk about um being able to
generate income so that you can Fus
focus on the things that really matter
in life um when I was at the hedge fund
it was all about money we that my our
clients would call there was Joe Joe was
one of our clients that would call every
Friday and his question was how much
money have you made us this week and and
I would sit down i' say Joe we're up
3.55% on the month and he said well we
were up only 2.5% last week when I
called you why did we only make 1% and
it was all about how much money are we
making and what do you expect to happen
uh over the next week and now that we're
now that I'm in this different stage yes
I'm still about the money I'm
competitive I'm one of Seven Brothers I
don't I everything is a competition with
me but the competition is being able to
help people make money so that they can
focus on what really matters it's not
about the money it's about being able to
have that income taken care of so that
you can take your grandkids out for ice
cream or so that you can go golfing with
your buddies or so that you can take
your wife on a on a cruise and and see
some sites that you you've never seen
before that's what really matters that's
what having multiple income streams is
really all about so let's say that I'm a
uh early 30s early mid-30s um uh a
married maybe a couple young kids yeah
uh I make um70 $80,000 a year I've been
kind of good in a sense of saying okay I
I'm uh I don't spend beyond my income
and I have a maybe a little bit you know
every every month that I can utilize to
put in some sort of Investments like how
do you start me on this path like what
you let's say that right now I don't
really I have maybe a 401k at work um
and uh but I don't really have I have a
little bit of savings uh but I don't
really have a plan and I'm I'm thinking
to myself gez you know 10 more years go
by and nothing much changes right this
is going to get a little stressful uh as
far as looking down the road a bit uh so
what kind of things would be like my
first steps to be able to create uh a
wealth breakthrough for myself yeah so a
wealth breakthrough happens one step at
a time uh and I think that you know that
for you as a 30 you know 30 some odd
professional um that breakthrough starts
by saying I need to have a plan and then
you step in and you begin to do the the
steps uh to accumulate that wealth and
so for for my conversation with somebody
like that would begin by saying uh my
service lifetime income report is all
about uh dividend stocks and that's also
where we talk about many of these
off-market income uh generating
strategies and so it would be an
opportunity to say all right let's put a
little bit of effort or let's put a
little bit of capital into these areas
and begin to to see these accumulate now
Albert Ein Einstein actually said that
uh compound interest which is the same
thing as incom was the eighth wonder of
the world and what he means by that is
it's amazing how fast wealth can grow
when you invest when you have income and
when you put that income back into New
Opportunities and so then you start to
earn income on the income that you've
already set aside and as that grows you
put more into these these multiple
streams of income and you you now have
more and more income coming through it's
just it's a it's a virtuous cycle of
more income being built so this
profession that we're talking about if
they spend the next 10 years just being
purposeful you don't have to we're not
going to decide not to ever go out to
eat with your family we're not going to
decide that oh you can't play my kids
can't play baseball because we're
putting that money aside for you know
for wealth building uh but just being
purposeful with a little bit at a time
and then as that grows continuing to
reinvest the income into new
opportunities as you build those
multiple streams of income that next 10
years is going to make all the
difference and what you said a a
stressful retirement or having a
retirement where you really you aren't
stressed you're focusing on the things
that matter in life so let's say that I
have $1,500 a month uh beyond my
expenses I can start to utilize uh for
multiple streams of income U and I know
probably there's a lot of questions you
need to ask before you can give a very
detailed thing but so would I spread
that out amongst the some of the things
you're talking about maybe buy some
dividend stocks uh would I be looking I
mean I don't know if I could do much in
real estate If I Only Had $1500 a month
so what would I be thinking about yeah
so again I I would not give individual
investment advice um but as far as being
able to broadly say somebody in that
category uh I think that it makes a lot
of sense to begin to invest in some
dividend stocks and when you invest in
two or three of those dividend stocks
you'll begin to get uh quarterly
payments that are paid back into your
brokerage account which will accumulate
meanwhile the stock prices if we're
investing in companies uh that have
growth built into their models those
stock prices are going to steadily move
higher and you're beginning to
accumulate that wealth then we can add
in some other strategies as well so as
that wealth begins to accumulate you can
start to spread it into different
pockets and we can start to look at uh
some of these others you you could
possibly look at some real estate you
could you could expand the number of
stocks so maybe you would have some in
energy maybe you would have some in
healthcare maybe you would have some in
manufacturing or Tech technology and
those as you as you begin to have more
and more areas of the economy covered
those are more and more areas of growth
um one of the things that uh that I've
talked to to our readers about a lot is
uh what I call a barbell strategy and
that is we're talking about one thing
here that is is is solid you know the
the dividend uh income generating
strategies but there are also some more
aggressive strategies that you can have
as well I'm not a get-rich person as you
probably guess from this this whole
conversation but there are times that it
makes sense to put some Capital into
other areas that potentially have much
more explosive growth much more exciting
growth opportunities and so one of the
things that I like to do is set up a an
approach where we have a solid base of
income generating assets over here and
then we take some of that income and we
put it on the other side of the barbell
and we say these are this is some
Capital that I'm willing to take a
little bit more risk I'm willing to be a
little bit more aggressive and I'm going
to see what happens and if if we invest
in something that does very well uh this
might double or triple very quickly and
we can pull some of that out and balance
it and put it back over here so now we
have more income being generated but if
something doesn't work out quite as well
as expected we still have a solid base
of income being generated here and we
can pull a little bit more out uh and be
able to to keep that barbell balanced
and that's a great way of of for a
younger uh investor of being able to be
aggressive when the time is right to be
aggressive but still not putting so much
at risk that you're risking not having
the goals that that you're shooting for
uh as you put this plan together are you
I guess you because you're writing and
and you you you have these newsletters
and this following um so are you still
doing analysis then is that kind of what
you're doing you're you're looking
around saying here I'm analyzing these
things these where I think some
opportunities are and are the what you
know at the time of this recording what
are some of the things you're writing
about
okay yeah so absolutely I'm doing a lot
of the analysis myself and and I love
that I will always enjoy uh being
involved in the markets and that's
that's kind of what gets me going and
gets me excited uh I'm now at a place
where I've got a team so we've got a
team at St Paul research and I'm able to
say Hey you take a look at some of the
energy stocks that that might be uh at a
good buying point right now hey let's
put a team together and focus on 5G and
um and this this roll out so one of the
things is is 5G that I'm really excited
about we've got um a whole new platform
of communication that is that is being
set up and it's going to drive
innovation in many different Industries
um and it's it's beyond just the telecom
companies so Verizon Sprint AT&T those
are some great companies that are going
to make money from it but think about
things like uh biotech as 5G is enabling
much more communication there's going to
be cures uh that are available much more
quickly simply because this computer
process processing and this this
communication between different doctors
and different networks is is being
enabled um we've talked a lot about
streaming media and Disney plus and all
Netflix and uh Google TV there there's
just so many entertainment opportunities
and my kids are telling me what we need
to subscribe to and not subscribe to
they your research assistant oh yeah
absolutely uh but that's another area of
growth uh but all a lot of this is all
being driven by 5G um another area is
the healthcare industry uh and that's
simply because of the expanding uh older
population so there's a lot more demand
uh for healthcare whether it be
facilities that can handle um so many
people or the different uh new cures and
and and different care that's being
that's being offered and so there's
there's a lot of opportunity for income
in those
areas um specifically think about uh
hospitals and and Care Centers uh that
are are going to be there no matter what
and these these places are generating
income and and many of these are set up
as companies that are they they reachs
which is Real Estate Investment Trust
Reit and these uh these type of
companies the way that these are set up
they're actually legally required to pay
investors uh 90% of the income that they
generate from leasing out beds or
leasing out uh doctor's offices for
Physicians and so forth so that's a a
really big area of opportunity right now
and then I think just plain old
manufacturing as as old and
old-fashioned as it sounds uh this is an
area that we've seen a lot of job growth
Creation in and we're also seeing a lot
of innovation now um so making a car is
not the same as it used to be making a
jet engine is not the same as it used to
be uh and many jobs are being created in
this area and much uh profit is being
created uh from traditional us
manufactur ing companies that's exciting
to see just as an American being able to
look at these companies and say these
companies are creating jobs and
opportunities for workers and at the
same time they're creating income and uh
and wealth Building Wealth breakthrough
opportunities uh for American investors
as well 5G is a new thing it's
controversial I know because some people
say hey we we're worried about
environmental you know issues but at the
the flip side uh I I think there's no
avoiding advancement of Technology it's
just coming it's coming one way or the
other and as you already sort cited you
know the fact that we can have this this
higher speed communication impacts a lot
of Industries but now I'm saying okay
this is coming I'm excited I want to
invest in it um and uh so if someone
decided that they did want to invest in
it uh what are the things they need to
know about 5G and and where to place
those bets because you talked about the
telecom companies but are they the best
places or what do you think well one of
the things that uh a lot of people don't
realize is that the big telecom
companies like AT&T Verizon those guys
guys they actually don't own the towers
that a lot of this equipment is being
put on and 5G is interesting because the
the latest cell phone towers all the
cell phone towers that have been in
place up to this point are several miles
apart um and you have a big beam that's
being sent for you know a long distance
uh but 5G is so powerful and yet it's so
Compact and so there's thousands of
different pieces of equipment that need
to be put within that you know 2 or
three mile radius that used to be
covered by just one Tower so you're
going from one Tower to thousands of
towers for every one of those and these
thousands of towers are all being owned
by different company or by a different
company they're not being they're not
owned by AT&T or Verizon and so these
Tower companies are able to charge rent
to the telecom companies they're
creating income from 5G telecom
companies and if you invest in these
Tower comp companies you can actually
participate in that income are they
public the they are they absolutely are
and they're they're set up as REITs or
real estate investment trusts and one of
the things with the Reit is that they
are required by law to pay income to
their investors they're able to avoid
paying income tax it's a special
loophole where they're able to avoid
paying income tax as long as they agree
to pay uh the majority of their income
to shareholders so that a great way for
us to invest in 5G for us to create one
of those another stream of income uh
from this new technology and it's kind
of off the beaten path most people don't
don't realize that these real estate
companies are actually some of the best
ways to invest in this Hightech 5G
technology that's coming out right now
so with a a public re you can get both
sides then in other words you're going
to get high dividend distribution it
sounds like and you know as the value
increases you're going to get a lift on
the stock side so the same thing yeah
because it sounds like the telecom
companies are probably going they're
going to get beat up in competition
against each other and they're going to
all be required to go 5G in order to
satisfy the demand of the consumer right
and they've got a lot of investment that
they have to put into those uh those
different pieces of equipment that are
going to be put out those thousands of
of different Towers yeah so now they've
got uh you so now they you know they're
kind of mandated in a sense by the
market to have to uh to use the towers
and the people who own and rent the
towers are going to be smiling all the
way to the bank it's a pretty good setup
I have to imagine based on everything
that you've uh been saying that um your
own definition of wealth has something
to do with um how you're living not just
how much money you're making absolutely
yeah um there's there's an old movie
quote um that that my family talks about
sometimes and I can't even remember what
the what the movie is from but there's a
there's a wise old person who says more
isn't always better sometimes it's just
more yeah and um I really think that's
true and I want to make sure that my
kids learn that as well just a little
side note uh my littlest kids uh I've
got 11-year-old Twins and a almost
seven-year-old little boy and they get
an allowance a $3 allowance every week
and they you know they've got chores
that they need to do and go to school
and get their homework done and all that
to get the allowance uh but the $3 is
important because there are three things
that you do with money you give you save
and you spend and so we've got envelopes
for each of those categories and you
know at the end of the week Friday they
get home from school and I give them the
$3 and we're talking about all right so
with the giving money what do we do with
this you know are there children in our
neighborhood who don't have Christmas
gifts that we can buy Christmas gifts
for are there um you know is there a
soup kitchen that we can give money to
but also go help with that as well uh
saving I help I'm I'm I'm helping them
think through maybe when they graduate
from high school they can do a special
trip or maybe when they get their
driver's license we can put some money
together for you know for a cheap car
for them to buy but something that they
can look far out into the future and say
I'm going to save this money and even
invest it in in different stocks you
know maybe companies that they are
actually familiar with um Disney or uh
Crocs the the little shoe company or
something like that that they can
actually see how all that works and then
of course we go out to get ice cream
with the spending money or something
like that but I think that's important
to to teach them and I think that kind
of ties back to your question about what
does wealth really mean and it means
being able to to have the money for
those things that really matter to be
able to give to be able to be be
generous with the wealth that you've
given to be able to save to to know that
if something happens in the future that
you've got something set aside uh so
you're not afraid of an unexpected
expense uh popping up and then to be
able to spend to be able to actually
enjoy uh the wealth that you've that
you've built uh and whether that be
lavish something like a cruise or
whether that be something as simple as
going to the grocery and and buying
enough stuff to come home and cook a
special dinner for your loved one none
of that is tied to a a specific dollar
amount all of that is tied to a concept
of of wealth and wealth breakthrough
that actually focuses on what matters in
life and that's different for every
person in your hedge fund experience you
worked with you know the you know what a
lot of people like talked about the one
the top 1% or what have you but the the
very wealthy people Y and now you you
youve seem to be writing for uh maybe
the average person uh you know more
moderate income person uh what do you
see as the difference between rich
people and people who want to be rich
but haven't gotten there yeah um I would
say the big difference is that the the
wealthy people uh have gotten income
figured out they understand how to put
those multiple streams of income
into play and their wealth is working
for them so they no longer have to be
putting in you know the the 4050 60
hours a week at their job they have set
up those those different income streams
and we saw it all the time uh at the
hedge fund that that I worked at so uh
Joe was one of our clients that would
call in every Friday and I would talk to
him about what was going on in the in
the fund Joe was an an oil man he you
know he got his start getting his hands
dirty um in the oil fields but he
figured it out he was able to to buy a
stake in a well and then he used that to
be able to buy a steak in another well
and he ended up having income literally
come out of the ground um and then use
that income to invest in other things
and eventually he was investing in our
hedge fund which was giving him
additional income um so that was that
was one of the ways that you know the
the rich and wealthy uh he had his
income figured out uh we had another
another client who was she was an ays to
the Coca-Cola uh Fortune which you could
think everything was given to her and
and in some ways it it was but she was
at a place where she allowed this
business that had been created to
generate income and she was able to
focus on the things that really mattered
in her life uh I remember she was
actually on a on a trip with her kids
and her grandkids uh when a particular
uh piece of paperwork came up that we
needed to get uh some documents sign for
tax sment we we came up on this and we
literally had like 24 hours to get these
documents signed and I I drove six hours
to this uh to this dock she was on an
island that could only be accessed by
ferry and she drove over from from the
island on the ferry met me at the dock
signed the papers drove him back but
those are the kind of um kind of high
touch things that we were able to do to
help people with their generating their
income or to protect their income um but
that's the difference between you know
the the 1% and the the people who maybe
haven't had this figured out yet as you
build that income as it continues to
accumulate as that um the the eighth
wonder of the world compound interest
kicks in uh you you're able to to have
those multiple streams of income and
that's what really uh creates this this
virtuous cycle um and that's what the
the really rich have already figured out
well uh very enlightening so love your
your story I think it really speaks a
lot about you know what your philosophy
is around all this and uh you know the
the ideas of multiple streams of income
and and how to get from point A to point
B I think is really critical for people
to know and understand so I I appreciate
you coming and sharing all that
absolutely thanks for having me we are
over the moon excited about the feedback
we're getting from the wealth
breakthrough series and I want to give a
very sincere and special thank you for
those who bought the series it supports
us supports our work allows us to get
this out to the world for free so people
everywhere can have their wealth break
through but for those who bought the
series it's especially heartening to us
to be able to know that you're
supporting this work so we can do what
we do every single
[Music]
day
hey welcome back this next interview is
another one of my favorites Rick
sheffron is the most famous and in-
demand business building expert in
America today if you're thinking of
starting a business if you own a
business Rich has one sentence to tell
you that will ensure your competitors
can't compete with you and he's about to
show you the one key difference between
a million doll business and A1 million
doll business and I know this seems like
too much right rich wants to show you
how you can start an internet business
from scratch right from your home and
grow it beyond your dreams let's get to
it rich thank you for being here with us
my pleasure so tell us a little bit
about who you are and and um what you do
really where you got started well what I
do and what I've done for about the last
decade and a half has really helped
companies grow online been working with
Agora since about 2004 um primar outside
the company as a consultant and then for
the last two years uh I've been working
inside the company but all with the same
purpose of just helping companies grow
and thrive in an online environment well
this I remember the early internet
marketing Manifesto I literally printed
that out and carried that with me and I
wasn't even sure what I was holding so
your name has been around a long time
tell us how you got started because
you're really one of the Pion ear yeah
so um let's see um I'll skip my Early
Childhood just because like we could
talk about that for hours right but I'd
say my business career uh kind of
started in college I was an accounting
major and uh won a lot of scholarships
from Arthur Anderson actually took a
year off uh my junior year and worked
for Arthur Anderson in all divisions and
that was when Arthur Anderson and
Anderson Consulting were one company
it's now called the centure and I got a
chance to work uh in tax and audit and
Consulting and in strategic Services
which is like their high-end Consulting
Division and that was a great experience
I learned more about business probably
in that year uh than any other time in
my life and really caught the business
bug then I went back to school to finish
up my senior year and after the during
the first semester um my dad called me I
was having a conversation with my dad he
owned a clothing store in Manhattan uh
that was upside down it was due in about
about a million and a half dollars a
year the break even was about 3 million
and the lease was coming up like in
about 6 months and he told me he wasn't
going to renew the lease and it wasn't a
big part of his business it was like
some side thing so I made him an offer
uh I said let me drop out of school let
me take over the store uh if I can make
it to break even or better in the next 6
months uh then I'll own half the store
going forward and I'll compensate you
for any money that you lost when I start
when I took over
of course I had to sell that to my mom
dropping out of school wasn't high on
her list of accomplishments she wanted
me to have but uh convinced her moved
back to New York took over that store
and at that time that store really
sucked and that's why it didn't do so
well ended up having to fire everyone
and kind of restart the store from
scratch get rid of all the clothes that
were in that store and then it was
really up to me to figure out like how
am I going to make this thing successful
like what can I do that different than
all the major retailers than you know
how am I going to compete with Urban
Outfitters how am I going to compete
with The Gap uh Etc because we were on
Broadway it was a highly competitive uh
retail environment that block or those
blocks and so this was really I guess
the first place where I started
developing some of my own business
Concepts and what what what occurred to
me was that the one thing that I knew
that other people didn't know uh was the
club life because I was a club kind of
kid back then going out to places like
the tunnel Palladium and stuff like that
big dance clubs and so that culture of
like the club culture is how is the
direction I took the store and so at
first I went to companies like overseas
like Diesel and a bunch of other
companies that weren't at that time in
the US like asking them to sell me
clothes that I could resell and they all
said no um but over time we changed the
store uh bit by bit uh doing all the
construction ourselves cuz cuz we had no
money um and turned the store into like
the hots spot in Manhattan because it
was lit like a club the employees looked
like they were going out to a club and
the clothing reflected that and then
diesel did sell us and so we were the
first store in the United States to sell
diesel and a bunch of other brands and
then one day like in in retailing uh you
want to maximize your your sales per
square foot that's how you kind of look
at it right and occurred to me that you
know I wasn't doing anything to maximize
the square footage of airspace and so I
started thinking about that and then the
idea occurred to me like oh we could
fill the store with music that we sold
right and this is back before like
Starbucks had their CDs Starbucks didn't
exist back then but no store was really
doing that and I've always had this
philosophy and it's stuck with me to
this day I still teach it different is
better than better that different is
always EAS easier to spot than better
like better is very subjective but
different is very obvious and so the
store looked different than any store
and so we didn't just play music like we
actually put DJs in the store and they
were spinning records we licensed that
music and we sold the crap out of that
music because you know every salesperson
would be telling their customers like oh
do you like the music oh we we spend it
here you can buy the records right and
so we started selling a lot of Records
we sold so many they were actually CDs
but we sold so many of those CDs that uh
we then built a recording studio right
in the middle of the store and it was an
electronic music uh studio and at this
time like we had most celebrities were a
lot of celebrities were shopping in the
store Madonna shopped in the store Eric
Clapton I sold him a leather jacket um
almost every celebrity like Drew bore
came in a lot um anyway lots of people
right and uh now the store was even
different we had our own recording
studio right in the middle of the store
double pain very thick glass so that
people could actually look in and see
what was going on and at that time just
by luck electronic music became very
popular Madonna was doing stuff with
electronic music The Chemical Brothers
Etc they all Madonna wasn't in my studio
but The Chemical Brothers were and a
bunch of other names that if someone
follows electronic music like Jeff Mills
Sasha and digweed these guys were all
recording in the store and it was just
another way to make the store unique and
different than any other store that
people were in and so we got the sales
from a million and a half to about uh 3
million uh within those 6 months which
was pretty awesome uh and we also
reduced what the break even was so we
were actually a little bit profitable
and then over the next two years we got
it up to 7 and a half million yeah 7 and
a half million and uh then we were going
to do this big deal in
Japan uh this group of companies was
going to license our concept and uh
build stores all over Japan and it was
really exciting and I was going to get
really wealthy and so it was I was
flying back and forth to Japan a lot uh
all these companies that had come
together I think it's called like ketsu
or something like that um where that's
it's like the biggest record company in
Japan the biggest Club company in Japan
one of the biggest clothing
manufacturers in Japan one of the
biggest real estate owners of stores in
Japan like they all come together and
then they do this business then the
company that was orchestrating it was a
trading company called sumkin bassan I
don't even know if they're still around
but uh as we were about to Ink the deal
uh two things happened uh one was my dad
told me that uh you know obviously
you're not going to get 50% of this and
I was like no that's not very obvious to
me at all uh in fact I think it's
obvious that I do um so we had a little
bit of conflict there and then the
Japanese economy tanked uh and so then
there was no deal um and because of I
was really disheartened by the fact that
there was no deal and then on top of
that recognizing that that like I was
never going to really be able to break
out like there was always going to be
this conflict with my dad I was like you
know what I've had enough I gave him
back to business and decided to take
some time off and then figure out what I
was going to do next so I I got to ask
you one the thing that occurs to me you
so first off the store idea sounds great
like it would actually work right now
it's still a a great idea but going back
before you really had the idea when
you're still at school MH and your dad
tells you he's going to close the store
what in the world made you think you
could do this I guess I've always had
a uh
unsubstantiated
probably um
irresponsible level of confidence in
myself you know it's uh when I'm
watching I'm a big UFC fan and uh until
I actually got into the cage with the
UFC fighter and he went at like 5% and
even at 5% like I was on the floor you
can do it I'm like I could do that like
everything I see I'm like I could do
that and then uh reality comes in right
most of the time uh but in this
particular case I was right and it
wasn't easy at first but we figured it
out and uh and we used a lot of advanced
stuff like I really educated myself on
retailing with open to buy systems and
understanding how inventory levels
change we turn the store five times a
year which meant that uh basically you
know five times new inventory all the
way through so that meant and I was
accountant by back by training right so
that meant we had to sell 10% of our
inventory every week in order to turn
the store five times a year anything
that's selling better than 10% we needed
to get on top of and reorder as quickly
as possible anything that was selling
less than 10% we had to first move to
see if it was a bad location in the
store and if it didn't then pick up we
had to drop price get it out of the
store as quickly as possible because
newness always sold best in retail and
we didn't want someone's experience to
come into the store one week then come
in the next week and everything be the
same right like if it's different every
time it gives people a reason to keep
coming back and so that was kind of we
mastered a lot of the fundamentals of
retailing but then also purposely tried
to do as many things as possible
different from your traditional like
store right so the music was loud right
and you know some people hated it um but
whether they hated it or loved it
they would remember it different is
better than better exact I got it and
I'm also heing you know you're as you're
retailing you know so this confidence
that that you you know you say you may
not have a right to but this this
confidence is is what I think stands in
a lot of people's way that literally
this um you know people ask me how to
make films you know how do you become a
filmmaker and the answer is make a film
exactly like stepen Spielberg was you
walking around with a camera in the eth
grade and making films and so but the
backup to it where then you actually did
the work of learning what retail really
was yeah and not to go too far deep into
it but like my background like my
childhood does like kind of prepare me
for that so uh I haven't really kept it
a big secret my dad was a sociopath and
so he kept me by his side and I watched
him like be ruthless in business right
like ruthless um uh never knew that like
he would be ruthless with me which is
another whole other story that we won't
go into today uh he's no longer with us
but so um but so yeah so I I I
understand what coldblooded business is
like um ran away from home when I was
14 um and the the movie Goodfellas is
based on a book called Wise Guys and
when I ran away from home I ended up
with a few people that were in the book
Wise Guys never in the movie Good Fellas
and and so I then got to understand how
the mob worked and spent about a year
hanging out as a gopher like go getting
them stuff uh at the track they were
fixing horse races they were paying a
bunch of jockeys to not come in first
second and third so that only they knew
the three horses that would end up in
first second and third and they would
bet What's called the trifecta box and
uh cover all the different angles and
the amount of money that was made was
insane and I got to make some of that
money too so uh then one day my dad
walked in to my bedroom when I was like
14 or 15 I had $15,000 and 20s uh on my
desk because all the gangsters cash
their tickets first and the track didn't
have any hundreds or 50s left uh that's
how much they took out so uh that was
the end of that um then uh my parents
told me I should get a job so now I'm in
11th grade and I got a job at a
brokerage firm called investor Center
and if you've seen The Wolf of Wall
Street that that's where he that strip
mall brokerage firm which wasn't in a
strip mall but uh that was where Jordan
bford got his start and so I saw the
penny stock business and saw like the
SLE factor in that um so I I've been
around business my whole life right and
I've seen good and bad good and bad and
and so uh I guess that also kind of has
given me confidence that I can handle
myself in a lot of different situations
so anyway so I got out of the store and
took some time off and I was living in
New York at the time and there was a
magazine called timeout it's still there
um and timeout had this article about
this hypnotist like you know one of the
editors went for hypnosis for some issue
and I'd always been curious about
hypnosis so I was like I want to try
that um so I made an appointment uh got
hypnotized and surprised like I'm highly
hypnotizable so it was a profound
experience for me and because it was a
profound experience for me I started
doing it more often like I would go for
more appointments and then as I went for
more appointments I wanted to start
learning it so then I started studying
NLP and hypnosis uh studied from bandler
like the founders of NLP and took a
bunch of classes on hypnosis and then I
decided I wanted to open a hypnosis
business and since I didn't think I was
a great hypnotist but I knew that I knew
business and I looked at the market and
saw just a bunch of mom and pop like
cottage industry type of businesses in
hypnosis
I thought that I could be dominant and
so we opened up a hypnosis Center on
36th in Lex in Manhattan uh at first
like we rented this big space but we
only renovated like we got six months
free rent because of the buildout but we
only finished like two of the rooms
because we didn't know if it would work
and I thought I knew a lot about
marketing and advertising because I had
turned this horrible store into one of
the most popular stores so I was pretty
confident that like I could do the
marketing for this this what I quickly
found out though was that this was a
totally different type of advertising
this was direct response advertising
right and so what I found was the more I
like the ad the worse it did the more
cheesy embarrassing the ad was the
better it did right and so that opened
my eyes to like there was a lot of stuff
I didn't know and so that put me into
the world of direct response right where
I started learning copywriting and
writing my own ads and that put me in
touch with people like Gary Halper and
Jay Abraham and and those kinds of
people right and I remember that you
know and we were running ads in The
Daily News and uh at first we started
with a half page then a full page and
then we're doing full Pages Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday and
Sunday or Saturday I don't remember one
of the week and uh a full page ad when
we first started would get us about 40
calls by the time like we could do split
tests really easy half the paper one way
half the paper the other way and we
change one element at a time and over
like a year and a half two years we got
up to about about 450 calls so about 11x
right and uh I heard about this guy Dan
Kennedy so I bought I went to eBay
bought the mother of all Dan Kennedy
offers which was this huge box probably
weighed like 50 pounds of VHS tapes and
cassette tapes and I put the first video
in and it was you know some copyrighting
seminar but he was talking about
newspaper advertising and things like
that and uh in the first 30 minutes he
covered everything I had learned by
spending at that point like or $3
million in newspaper advertising that I
thought maybe I was the only person that
knew and realized oh like I could have
been making a lot more a lot sooner had
I had this videotape earlier this is all
out yeah so so I started to uh consume
everything I could from Dan Kennedy from
Jay Abraham Etc and uh that like we
continued to grow we did 13 we were
headed towards 13.5 million in 2001 uh
we opened in '97 or '98 and and uh then
uh 9/11 happened and nobody wanted to
change their life after 911 we also lost
like our phone lines for a couple of
weeks because FEMA needed them and so
like we like took a major hit and we
were basically a direct response company
with a big infrastructure cost like I
had 60 full-time hypnotists on staff I
had like you know at this point I had
three offices we were opening a fourth
we were in Two in Manhattan one in
Brooklyn one in queens and uh it quickly
became too much and also that bravado
that confidence like so at up till this
point I had been successful in the music
business been successful in the clothing
business been successful in the hypnosis
business so I didn't really think that
there was any problem I couldn't handle
you're bulletproof yeah yeah uh but
found out I wasn't and uh and actually
lost a lot of the money IID made by just
throwing good money after bad at trying
to turn this thing around and I was kind
of stuck too because a lot of people
paid us uh in full for programs right
and the way Merchant accounts work like
you have to sign personally for a
merchant account and uh the way like it
works with the credit cards if someone
buys a year-long program and you go out
of business in 11 months then that
person's entitled to a refund they don't
prate it they like so I was on the line
for like I don't know like six or 7
million um my dad told me I should go
bankrupt uh um although my whole life
growing up he told me that uh he was so
proud that he never went bankrupt so I
wasn't going to go bankrupt uh so I
ended up like making it a skeleton crew
so I could service out everyone started
selling shorter and shorter and shorter
programs so that we could ultimately
close shop right and so after I Clos
shop then the next thing was well now
what right and there's some stories in
between but it would just take too long
to cover right um but I was left with
the decision of like what am I going to
do now and how am I going to live and I
just had a baby and well I didn't have
mine but uh and you know my wife didn't
work and so like it was up to me to
figure out like what am I going to do I
really like the direct response side um
but I hated the employee side and so I
started like reading about the internet
and back then this is like
2002 uh there was a lot of people like
selling a dream over you know open your
laptop for an hour a day at the beach
and make all this money right and I
bought into that um especially because I
was so anti- employee because like my
payroll was insane and I you know I had
to sweat payroll God knows how many
times like during the bad time towards
the end uh that the whole idea of having
a business that solely relied on my
skill in direct response and nothing
else was Uber appealing to me and so
that's what started me online but
because I had that mindset I didn't go
very far and actually I spent the next
two years kind of struggling online like
I would make a little bit enough to kind
of get by but just barely right and so
one night in my journal like I was
venting I've been keeping a journal for
like 30 years and and I I was venting
about like my lack of progress like why
hav was I so successful in all these
other businesses and now I'm not
successful and barely making it like is
it you know did I change um am I doing
something wrong and so I started listing
out like all the things I'm supposed to
be doing and very quickly it became
overwhelming when I looked at it and it
was clear to me in that moment that like
no I need to treat this business like
I've treated all my other businesses
like you know when I was in the hypnosis
business as soon as we got some momentum
I stopped hypnotizing right I ran the
business when I had the clothing store I
didn't make the clothes I didn't sell
the clothes I didn't ring up the clothes
right uh in the music business I'm very
tone deaf and can't you know I don't
know much about music but I ran the
studio right so it occurred to me that
oh okay I got to treat this business
like any other business I got to look
for key people that can make me money I
got to look for scalability I got to
look for certain things that I've always
looked for in every other business and
when I did that uh things radically
changed for me so I started making a lot
of money online I was in the baby Niche
at that time and I think we had about 30
or so ebooks 20 to 30 I don't remember
like teacher toddler how to walk get
your baby to sleep through the night
like all kinds of things like that right
and we use this script that where back
then it was very popular to have like
what's called a squeeze page or name
capture page right where someone enters
in their name and email address and then
goes to the sales letter well what we
did is we had a squeeze page but it was
name you know email address your baby's
name your baby's date of birth right and
we use that information to populate the
sales letter so the very first first
ebook that I had in the baby Niche was
about baby modeling because both of my
daughters were baby models uh one of
them was the face of Downey it was
$100,000 from Proctor and Gamble um so
that was the first book that was written
and people would fill that out and then
like when they got to the sales letter
it would have their name like their
baby's name right like all over the
place but what we also did was we kept
track of the average age of a baby of
the buyers right and as we added more
and more of these ebooks we knew the
average age of the baby for each product
and we knew the we knew the age of every
baby on our like we had the parents
email of their baby so we knew how to
sequence our offers based on the average
age of the you know of the traditional
buyer and their age of their baby and
then we started B doing affiliate sites
where like affiliate sites for strollers
and all kinds of things like that where
I made basically very little money but I
was getting free buyers right so you
know I could trade on the names of
popular baby products and use them to
capture more leads for this business and
like what was different now than before
was is every time I created a new ebook
uh I had a built-in customer base for it
so the day it went live I already made
all my money back plus and then that
became a feeder mechanism for all my
right so that's why like my results
started to grow uh pretty big but I was
never really that interested in the baby
Niche it was just an opportunity and so
uh I had been going to internet
marketing seminars and there were a
bunch of people that were my friends and
we were struggling together and then all
of a sudden I was really successful kind
of cracked that nut and so I started
helping friends and I found that I
really enjoyed it I love talking
business like I couldn't get enough of
it I love studying business and so as I
started helping more and more friends I
was like you know what I'm going to try
and make this into my business right and
I had a couple interactions with Jay
Abraham like early on from uh a bunch of
different things back in the hypnosis
business so I called him and I was in a
coaching program by by by the guy by the
name of Stephen Pierce who was a big
deal on the internet way back and we did
a series of calls together teleseminar
series uh sold it extremely well and
that was like the first time that I was
out in public right um teaching anything
other well teaching anything period and
uh what was interesting was is that then
from there we did a backend of a
coaching program that was also me Jay
and stevenh and at the end of that
coaching program we had to we gave away
like a free event and it was a non-
pitch event it was like you know to end
the six months of coaching we're GNA do
this event and Jay had spoken on a
gazillion stages Stephen had I'd never
spoken before
and uh and just as it turns out I'm
actually more comfortable speaking on
stage than speaking to a stranger
there's a certain amount ofinity right
uh so I but I didn't know what to talk
about and so I created three different
presentations and one of the
presentations was about like the
struggle I went through what I figured
out and then what life was like after
and uh that's where like my U diagram
that was like the beginning of my
Manifesto without me knowing it uh it
was by far the most impactful
presentation of the event like not only
my most but the most and some people
were crying some people like oh my God
you've explained my life and so I was
like oh okay that's interesting and we
had oversold this coaching program we
were going to take like 500 people and I
think we ended up taking 1500 people so
we did three groups so we had three
seminars to do you know one after
another not right you know not the next
week but like month later month later
and Jane Steven had a falling out and so
great and I was the lowest guy in the
totem pole I was doing all the work uh
but I was getting exposure so I was
happy um so at the last the last group
we didn't do the normal event Stephen
was already doing an event that was
going to be a Pitch Fest and we just
like gave PE those that last group that
event right and so my relation this
profitable relationship was now ending
right because Stephen and Jay didn't
even want to be in the same room
together they both were fine with me but
that didn't matter right so it was time
for me to do something else and I
remembered that presentation resonating
so much so I decided like I'm going to
pitch and uh I'm going to use that
presentation to do my pitch right and I
was afraid that no one would buy so I
did it by application only so that I
wasn't worried about like a big table
Rush at the end where everyone runs back
to buy and figured I had to give a
guarantee so I guaranteed people that
they would double the amount of money
they make and cut their work hours in
half or it would be free and I was
personally coaching right I was doing
one-on-one coaching and then some group
like all of them in a group I would
teach but then I'd get on the phone with
each one individually so the last thing
I wanted to do was work with someone for
a whole year and then give them back all
their money because it wasn't just like
media cost it was my time so I got about
like 40 some odd applications and of
those 40 some odd I whittled it down to
maybe like 30 and then I got on the
phone with those 30 and then picked 25
cuz I felt like 25 was the limit that I
could really handle and fortunately I
picked really well uh so some of the
people that were in that group was Ryan
dice uh who started digital marketer uh
Mike fils who's a well-known internet
marketer tman kutson another well-known
internet marketer one shopping cart um
and a bunch of other names that people
would recognize Russell Brunson of
clickfunnels like you know Etc and got
everyone amazing results and also there
a little bit lucky um didn't know it at
the time but like I was talking about
business and business growth and the
majority of people out there the
majority of businesses out there are
constrained by their marketing at the
end of the day like the reason they're
not double the size is because their
marketing is not powerful enough to get
them double the size but at that time uh
in that group the people that my message
res ated with were marketers who were
actually not growing because of their
business knowledge not because of their
marketing skill a unique breed because
like that's a much easier problem to fix
right right like these people knew
nothing about project management they
knew nothing about hiring they knew
nothing about like any of the just nuts
and bolts of business that I had already
become very familiar with so as I taught
this and I saw like the the change right
like Mike Fain went from making 10,000 a
month to $300,000 a month uh there was a
couple Hans and Danny Johnson Danny
Johnson's pretty well known uh to some
groups uh when they started they were a
half a million dollar a year business
and they were a $6 million business by
the end of the year and it was primarily
because I just helped them streamline
like what they did get clear about their
strands to core competencies and then
figure out how to build the business
around that and I also I guess like
another unique way of looking at things
and I tend to look at things just
differently it might be like an add
thing which I have um but I felt like
most people when they designed a
business they designed a business around
their ideal self not their real self
right good point yeah so like I'm a
procrastinator I'm a perfectionist like
I'm a flawed individual with like my
flaws right so like I could design a
business that would pretend that those
things didn't exist but then that
business would probably fail so instead
like more realistic was how do I build a
business as a perfectionist as a
procrastinator and make it work so like
As I Grew my business right so after I
coached these people and I'll get back
to that in a second but after I coached
these people um I had one group I did a
second group and that second group was
ending and three months later I had a
deal with Agora that I was going to be
working on something with them so I
ended my second group and I had this
three-month window where no money was
going to be coming in and I didn't have
anything to do and I was like damn
that's not a good position to be in it
took me actually 18 months I sold it as
a year-long program but it took me 18
months to deliver but I was like maybe I
can compress it all into 11 weeks and
just get like a dozen clients or 10 and
just have something to do have money
keep coming in until like my project
with Agora and so I wrote a document and
the document was called the internet
business Manifesto and it was based on
my experience of be failing online to
succeeding online and what the
difference was uh same as the
presentation just written out and uh lo
and behold like unbeknownst to me that
those 30 pages would totally change my
life um
within 6 weeks uh we had
sold about 13300 people um I was hoping
for 10 or 12 um so all of a sudden like
I built a company uh to service all
these people uh I was coaching at that
time 187 people uh which meant that uh
each one a half an hour every other week
so I was basically on the phone for 50
hours a week just doing one coach call
after another which wasn't bad because
it was I was making 3,000 bucks an hour
like when you netted it out and I'm
sitting by my pool at this point in
Florida giving advice and uh and once
again making it work for me so like you
know I'm not going to read anything
before we get on the call you got to
know what you need to ask me because
that's real life like there are
opportunities in life where you might be
able to get an answer but you better
know the question and uh if you're
expecting me to know your question then
you're in the wrong place right that's
how I could do like back to back to back
to back calls and uh that model though
really worked for me like write a report
right change the beliefs of the Mind
mindsets of the market because at that
time like when I wrote the internet
business Manifesto everyone was all
marketing all the time right and I came
in and said look if you're not
successful there might be a good reason
for it and it's not that you're wrong
right but you're missing something you
need to understand business of which
marketing is the most important piece
there's no doubt that what you're doing
is important but you're missing one
other piece which is the best advice for
anyone to hear when they're not getting
the result and they're doing a lot of
things right not that they're totally
wrong there's just one thing wrong right
right and so that's why that message
kind of resonated so deeply um and so
the
that model of like writing a report
changing people's belief showing them
where they were off and then coming
behind that report with a program worked
for who I was and it worked for who I
was because then when the program was
live because every product I ever
created I first had as a live program
which meant that like every Wednesday I
had to show up with a presentation and
my perfectionism my procrastination all
that stuff just and ended up me pulling
all nighters and all nighters so that
that Wednesday I wouldn't be humiliated
and have to return all that money right
and so I did seven or eight programs
like that and that's one way that I made
my flaws not important I had designed a
business that could Thrive even with the
way I was that worked so well that I
looked at every other area of my life
where maybe I wasn't the ideal
entrepreneur and tried to maneuver the
business so that the business business
could still act like it was driven by a
really effective entrepreneur so another
area was that I've never really been
Money Motivated like the only time I'm
Money Motivated is when I don't have any
uh but other than that once I have some
I'm generally not like super ambitious
want to take over the world want to have
private jets private yachts that's just
not who I am so uh but obviously uh
business someone has to be really
concerned about making money or the
business isn't going to make any money
something that uh Mark Ford once shared
with me he's like the natural state of a
business is no profit because you have
customers who always want more for less
you have vendors who always want to sell
you less for more right you have
employees that want to do the least and
get paid the most so like you have all
this pressure on a business to make no
money and you have to be like that piece
of sand in an oyster that turns into a
pearl by causing friction so that those
things don't happen right like you have
to be the buffer that so that those
outside forces don't really make it
happen I love that comment yeah and that
was Mark um and so uh what I did was I
put in a very aggressive profit sharing
plan um set a benchmark like each month
of what we had to hit just for continued
growth and then anything above that
number 20% of it was spread out to the
team and my team was small it was like
10 people so most people made they got
good salaries like I paid uh more than
average but the profit sharing made them
paid very highly and every week they
would get the financial reports and
every week they would meet as a team
without me like looking at where they
were figuring out like how are we going
to maxiz sales like this week next week
and then the final week them knowing
that every 20 cents of every dollar is
going in their pockets um was very
incentivizing for them and we continued
to grow the that also helped me
uh start taking money out of the
business too because early on like with
the clothing business I left most of the
bu money in the business with the
hypnosis business I left most of the
money in the business which made it
easier to go through millions of dollars
because like it was in the business bank
account right like I found it was always
better to take out as much as I could I
could always put it back but it's a lot
it gets you thinking a lot more when
you're writing personal checks to your
business for the privilege of working
there and um um and so it was like a
good thing by giving the employees 20% I
also took 20% I gave my right-and guy
10% and uh and so that was just a very
effective model of continued growth what
happened though with the reports and all
of that was I figured out uh sometime
later that the I still had problems in
my business things I didn't like and as
I figured out why it was that we had
built a business based on these reports
doing a launch around around it and then
selling all our people at one f one time
actually I was learning something called
theory of constraints where you look at
like a business and you look for deeper
causes like the core causes of the
business's problems and as I was
learning it I tried to play around with
it I actually taught a course on it and
uh when I did it for my own business the
problems all stemmed from having a
launch based business so explain for
somebody who's watching this and doesn't
know what a launch based business a
launch BAS business is where you get a
bunch of other businesses uh to all
promote your business uh for a limited
period of time and there's generally
contests for like which Affiliates which
other businesses are selling the most of
your stuff right and uh it sets up like
an a big like
artificial uh
urgency
um uh promotion Etc and then you sell
out maybe fast maybe slow um and then
it's over and then all those other
businesses go on to promote either
another business or their own stuff and
now like there's no one promoting right
and so it's off and on off and on right
and so I'd get like all my customers in
one week that would lead to customer
service problems right that would lead
to just a lot of stresses on the
business because like you know we
weren't it wasn't trailed out over 52
weeks the other thing was is that I
started making less and less with each
report even though the reports spread
was further and further because like we
had built out a really big team and the
team was trying to build like front-end
products that we could sell so we could
acquire customers in a different way and
uh they weren't effective like they just
never got the job done so I was
supporting this team at that time
because this is before the profit
sharing and stuff like that like about
25 people and I was just like this is
ridiculous because every time I wrote
wrot a report I had to like or we were
going to have a problem like accounts
payable was already growing uh like we
were headed towards a problem and then I
had to write a report to kind of save
the day so I told Brian the guy who was
running my business at the time I'm done
like I'm not writing another report I'm
not writing another report until this
business does not need me to write
another report and if this business goes
out of business it's fine with me
because then I'll write a report and
I'll keep all the money and I'll you
know I want you around so we'll sh that
but like I'm not supporting all these
people anymore uh we got to figure out a
different model so we went about trying
to create a new model and uh we started
slowly firing people uh because we
couldn't afford them and uh and then we
finally figured out a different model
and the different model was uh webinars
and we automated it so we were the first
to automate webinars this is back in
about 2008 so I wrote seven reports or
eight reports from 2006 to 2008 if you
add up all those pages I think it's
probably close to a th Pages um I was
tired um and uh we developed this
automated webinar and uh and all of a
sudden like once we not dialed it in we
were selling our back-end products every
day every hour like it was insane people
were like they didn't know it was
automated it all seemed like it was live
and it just seemed as if if any time
they got on like it was they were there
at the right time right right and so uh
that we started crushing it and I wrote
a report a private report not a public
like marketing report uh back in
2007 or eight uh on automated webinars
called it the Evergreen event driven
marketing uh process saying that
automated webinars were going to be the
next big thing and uh some of my clients
jumped on it right away uh some didn't
and and during that time uh the launch
model for others started breaking down
um a lot of people lost their merchant
accounts people like Russell Brunson of
clickfunnels Mike Phils lost his
merchant account uh at that time like
when Russell lost his uh he had to shut
down his company and he owed the
government over a million dollars in
back payroll taxes and back payroll
taxes sends you to jail like that's not
it's the one you're going to pay yeah
yeah and so Russell called me in a panic
and I'm like I got you handled man just
fly down here I'll give you the software
for the automated webinars I'll give you
like the report I wrote on it and I'm
I'm sure you can crush it so he did he
went back he made a million bucks I
don't remember now if it was 30 60 or 90
days paid off the government uh did
whatever he did and then ultimately
created clickfunnels I had nothing to do
with that but like I kind of did I guess
cuz like he wouldn't have been able to
have created it he's in your lineage
yeah and uh I also did the same thing
for Mike Fain and uh and so that got
Mike out of his problems and then Mike
created uh webinar jam and never webinar
which was based on the software that I
gave Mike uh to get him out of his
problem so that was from about 2008 till
about
2012 I'd say um and it was just like for
me it was the go- go years man like it
was like back in my early days when I
had the store and it was cranking out
money like now all of a sudden I had
this thing selling for me didn't have to
write reports didn't have to do anything
except show up once a week for a
coaching call which is actually
important because uh when I had my
hypnosis enters right the one problem
that I had with it one of the reasons
why I didn't want to rebuild it was that
about 80% well that might be an
exaggeration 70% of our clients were for
weight loss and when people came for
weight loss in general they weren't
coming to lose 10 lbs they were morbidly
obese and nothing had worked for them
and we got people great results but
great results in weight loss could be
like a 15% success rate like Weight
Watchers has a 5% success rate right
just to give people like a barometer so
as I thought about that there was two
problems with that one was if you fail
at Weight Watchers you generally blame
yourself if you eat a tub of ice cream
at midnight and you're paying for
hypnosis now it's the hypnosis
right very convenient right I'm you're
paying me to take over all your
responsibility so it occurred to me at
some point like in this time and it was
probably after like I was struggling
like if you took all the weight loss
clients that we ever sold you put them
into a room uh and they all just like
got to know each other and told each
other's stories uh I'd be afraid to walk
into that room not because we did
anything wrong but because 85% of the
people didn't get the result that they
wanted right and they paid a lot of
money for it
and I was like that's really shitty uh
excuse the language but that's I don't
want to be in a business where I'd be
afraid for all my customers to get
together yeah so one of the reasons why
I always had that group component and I
like I did it for 12 years a group
coaching call every week was I wanted to
step into that room like every week I
wanted a place where any customer could
call me out in front of all my other
customers to keep me like on the
straight and narrow like you know I'd
look at promotions like affiliate promo
ions or other things and ask myself like
could I defend this if someone asked me
on a coaching call right and if I
couldn't then I wouldn't do it and so
like that was just another thing knowing
that like maybe I might go a little bit
aside I'd never do anything that I
thought was wrong but maybe I wouldn't
like be clean and pure uh if I didn't
have that and that always served me well
like uh you know I've been one of the
few people I think that's maintained
like a really good reputation and when I
did a big PR otion back in
2012 uh which was already like you know
six years in the Limelight uh the video
started and I said like if you don't
know who I am you want to hear more
there's no testimonials on this page
what there is is on the right there's a
button and when you click that button it
will open up another window with my name
and quotes and search in Google you'll
see over 200,000 Pages there about me
and you'd be hardpressed to find any
single one page that is something bad
right and it was that
Weekly call they kept you on track kept
me on track uh so then in about
2012 the whole world was doing automated
webinars uh so ours were not anywhere
near as effective anymore show up rates
declined things like that and uh I'd
made enough money that I really wasn't
sure that I wanted to continue doing
this um so I took more time off uh I had
gotten separated then divorced I met
this other woman that I fell in love
with uh she came from the banking world
the private Equity world uh had a lot of
very big clients I thought about like
possibly going down that road I loved
being around smart people I've always
loved that and so like I thought about
maybe doing an internship which you
could help me get like at Blackstone or
one of the top you know hedge fund
private Equity companies but in the end
like the idea of wearing a suit every
day and having to do that just kept me
away from it so I ended up just
basically uh doing private clients for
about five years about till about
2017 um kept like two people in my
business just to kind of keep the
machines running one was an affiliate
manager one was my head of Tech a guy by
the name of Ry uh because they were so
integral to just keeping the lights on
in addition to that like I had already
set up licensing deals for for my
products overseas so like I have a
strategic profits of Japan and they sell
a lot of my my stuff so you know I still
have a nice cash flow come in just from
my I had people in Italy Germany like in
a bunch of other places right and uh in
2017 though I decided I wanted to get
back into the business uh and I didn't
want to do everything again myself like
there's a part of me that never wants to
do the same thing twice and I didn't
really so I didn't want to rebuild the
business and I also didn't want certain
of the responsibilities that come with
being the boss uh and so I approached
Mark Ford uh who had become like a
surrogate father to me and asked him
like he had made actually the very first
time I met him he had uh offered to buy
my business and I was like no thank you
but years later in 2017 I was like I
think I want to come into aora and I
think uh we could do something big right
and uh sometime around that time Mark
and miles or Mark and Bill I don't
remember which of the guys it was they
asked me if it was possible to have a
$100 million business in internet
marketing and I said yeah I think it's
totally doable it just was going to
require a bunch of gurus just like
you've done in financial and so uh that
was the start of me going from outside
of you know working outside of Agora
because like I had given them the vssl
which helped them grow about 300 to 400%
worldwide and uh came into ultimately
agore Financial I was trying to decide
between agore financial and Legacy and
uh just really like Joe
so much who runs Agora Financial that I
decided on Agora Financial I came in and
uh spent like really what I thought we
were going to just get my business off
the ground um it took me a long time to
find the right publisher uh I was also
an outside consultant to Agora Financial
so I spent a lot of time with Joe and
that kept me busy um then about I don't
know like about four months ago I got
put into a new imprint not a new imprint
new to me uh imprint called Paradigm
press and the publisher of that is named
Pete coin and for whatever reason Pete
and I like gelled well and so now like
we're in the steps of getting my
business off the ground again and uh
we're doing a big thing in February
February 26 that's the plan at least uh
and that will be when I make my big
return to the internet marketing space
well this it's funny going through this
history
I I hope people that are watching this
are picking up like this Trail is
littered with gold I mean that from the
you know the the the lessons that you
pulled out on you know at at one point
I'm um you know even you back in the
retail days where you're talking about
um being different well that's brilliant
but even the way you manage your
inventory starving your losers and
feeding your winners and keeping things
changing this is is absolutely Ely
brilliant from where you sit now if
someone is watching this and
they're they're of a temperament you
know for I believe people need to have
the right temper temperament for
entrepreneurship sure but think they
want to start an internet business but
way you know not like the clients you
consult with but at way the beginning
what would you tell somebody what should
they be looking at what are you seeing
from your Vantage Point well what I
would say is that is that first they got
to make sure they have the right mindset
right but I have a different little bit
of a different take about what that
means so a common question fortunately
not that common anymore but a common
question I used I used to get would be
like if I join your coaching program uh
how much money am I going to be making
in six months from now or a year from
now right and I'd be like that is the
stupidest question I've ever heard in my
life and let me tell you why I don't
know how much exactly my business is
going to be making in six months from
now nobody knows how much Apple's going
to be making making in 6 months from now
nobody knows what any business is going
to be making 6 months from now so anyone
who promises you a number is full of
and if that's what you're looking
for then you should not be an
entrepreneur like the way I see it is
there's two roads there's the illusion
of security and there's the reality of
uncertainty and you're going to walk
down the road of uncertainty as an
entrepreneur you're not going to know
that something's going to be a success
or a failure so what you can do the only
thing you can do is have confidence in
yourself right and the only way you have
confidence in yourself is if you do
things try things and know things and so
that's what they have to do they first
have to just recognize the fact that
anyone that's selling them anything that
has a guarantee attached to it is full
of crap because that's not the way
business works like here at Agora like
we have no idea before a sales letter is
released to the market whether it's a
winner or a loser right so we have great
years we have okay years we have some
bad years if we knew in advance that it
was going to be a bad year we'd change
it yeah we skipped that one um so I
think a lot of people go into
entrepreneurship just with the wrong
idea right out of the gate right um
because they're looking for that
security and that's just not what
entrepreneurship is about what
entrepreneurship is about is freedom and
what entrepreneurship is about is being
able to do your own thing and having the
confidence in yourself mean something
about your future so that's just like
the first step the other thing because
I've helped a lot of people start out
and do well I'd say that uh there's a
pattern right the first pattern is what
understand the game right like
understand what entrepreneurship is part
of what I just said is part of the way I
see it right another like couple quick
distinctions a lot of people think of
business as like their family and like
their team like the people that they
hire uh not really the right way to look
at things really it's a team it's not
your family and a team Cuts people who
don't produce tries to acquire great
talent a family is not like that and if
you run your business like a family
it'll probably go out of business
because you'll have fat that needs to be
cut Etc right and then the last thing is
like as far as just understanding the
game I see business as like the closest
thing you could be to God
uh that exists because you're creating a
living breathing thing that can live Way
Beyond you can grow bigger than you uh
that can employ lotss of people that can
be around for Generations if you do it
right so this is the closest thing to
being able to until they dial in cloning
this is the like the the the most
creative and most powerful like
experiment you can do well at the very
minimum you're emulating your creator
right by creating yeah so that's that
those are some of the beliefs that I
have about like what is the game of
business the next is to really
understand what is it that you bring to
the table because a lot of people make
the mistake of trying to build an online
business and they think that they're
going to learn how to create a product
like of some sort or something and
they're going to learn internet
marketing and they're going to learn
like advertising and they're going to
learn learn learn like you have to step
in with something so it took me two
years online to figure out that I knew
things about business that other people
didn't and until I figured that out
really uh I struggled right but that was
my point of difference that was what
gave me an advantage for everybody it's
going to be different you know some of
the things to think about are what do
people come to you for advice for like
what like when your friends have what
kind of problem where do they go to
right Steve Jobs has that really famous
commencement address at Stanford where
he says you can never connect the dots
looking forward you can only Look
Backwards right so looking backwards
what skills do you have what strengths
do you have what experiences have you
had that let you enable you to do
something that other people can't right
that allows you to solve problems that
other people can't right uh and so
that's like the next step like where's
the value right because if you're
building a business that is going to be
predicated on finding a lot of idiots to
buy from you it's probably not going to
last that long so you have to be the
best choice for somebody like whoever
that is and you know what's great is
that the internet is the whole world so
like you know Gary vanderchuck said this
once at one of my seminars he said look
it doesn't matter if you live in your
basement only wear green socks and hate
people like we're talking about the
whole world here like there are other
people who hate their parents live in
their basement only wear green socks and
you could be their leader right um so
you know everyone has something that is
of value it's just about figuring it out
and sometimes that's easier said than
done but uh they got to have that like
you know unless they have a great skill
like if you're a great media buyer then
you can build a business just off that
right if you're a great copywriter you
can just build a business off that that
uh if you know a lot about business you
can build a business off that um but
there has to be something and ideally
you specialize right because people just
automatically associate specialization
with greater expertise right and then
the next step I'm not going to go
through all of them but the next step is
you got to create an offer that is
irresistible so that first offer that I
did right where you're going to double
the amount you make cut the work hours
in half so it's really like a 4X of what
they put in versus what they get or
money back was a very appealing
proposition right because like you're
new they don't know you right doesn't
matter what kind of business it is like
what kind of offer can you make that's
going to get people to reach into their
wallet and hand over money and people
generally underestimate the difficulty
of that task right um so you need a
compelling offer to give you that
initial momentum to give you liftoff
right from there now it's all like the
general eneral fundamentals of business
right from project management because
there's only two ways things get done in
business either systems or projects
right if it's a continuous ongoing thing
it's a system if it's a one-time thing
it's a project right I find that most
entrepreneurs are untrained project
managers managing projects that their
whole life depends on right not smart
yeah so uh understanding project
management understanding
systemization and by that and I guess
like we'll we can move on after this
point but like with systems uh so a lot
of a lot of people make mistakes about
systems as well so some people come to
me and they want to systematize their
business that doesn't exist and it's you
don't build a system until you know you
can get the result because otherwise
you're systematizing something that may
or may not get a result and that seems
kind of stupid to me um so you try and
get the result in any way you can and
then you try and systematize the process
right but then the other thing is is
that looking at the problems of your
business the ones that's like come up as
a problem with the system so early on in
my online experience when I was doing
the baby sites I hired this guy named
Alex and he was my tech guy and he was
an idiot and I didn't know he was an
idiot because I know even less about
tech than he did um now Alex was an
idiot there's no question Alex was an
idiot right and Alex I'm sorry if you're
watching this uh but the TR that's the
truth but you know you already know but
but like you could look at that as
saying like I hired an idiot I need to
hire someone else and that's certainly
one way of looking at it but the
likelihood that you might have that
problem again is pretty high right so
instead of looking at it that way it's
like well okay so where was the
breakdown that I hired an idiot like did
I not interview well enough did I not
like check in like early enough to
figure out that this guy was an idiot
did I like where did the process break
down so that if that was there that so
much less damage would have happened or
maybe it would have never happened at
all and then from there how do I put
something in place so that that doesn't
happen right so most of the problems
that I fixed in my business I fixed with
a system so that the problem would never
happen again right and I learned project
management so that like projects that
got started actually ended and were
completed like on time on budget right
so there's those elements there's hiring
people managing people right and uh then
there's all the particulars of online
marketing right traffic conversion Etc
so there's a lot but what I would say is
is that you have to figure out what
parts of the game you're going to be
good at and really focus on those so I
know very few businesses that have grown
and gotten off the ground by trying to
master five different ways of generating
traffic you only need one to start right
one's the most dangerous number in
business but everything has to start
with one your first customer your first
like way of selling your first way of
driving traffic Etc and then I would say
as like an overall thing what worked so
well for me was start as a service
because then there's no investment like
you're not creating a product you're not
wasting time right and then turn that
service into a product and so my
original coaching program started as a
service I was a coach and then it was a
coaching program right that I only had
to show up once a week on Wednesdays and
answer questions I when I taught uh
theory of constraints same thing it was
a live program that then turned into an
automated program right so everything I
did was started as as a service because
I could sell it before I even delivered
it so I could determine whether it
worked or not and then after I delivered
it I had everything I needed to hand it
off to someone to create a product
around it and so I think anyone who's
serious about getting started should
really think about starting as a service
because it's so much easier to get a
service off the ground and then as they
experience any level of success uh
convert that service into a product that
then takes them out of the equation but
I'm a big believer in getting your hands
dirty like really understanding the
business doing what needs to be done
yourself uh and then pulling back and
putting in either systems or people to
pick up the slack so you mentioned that
you're you're starting a program in
February with with the people at Agora
so tell me just a little bit about what
you're doing yeah sure and it's it's not
a program like what I've always done
it's going to be something different
because it's Ator so it's going to be a
newsletter
um there's really like when I look at
the internet marketing space which yeah
I was one of the early pioneers of a lot
of people call me like an OG or Guru to
the gurus right um there were a lot of
gurus out there they were all well known
um there were like preferred people that
you knew you could trust now there's
been a proliferation of gurus you don't
know who's real who's just selling
recycled material and doesn't really
know I've seen a lot of the stuff that
I've taught been taught by others taught
to others taught to others and now it's
nothing like it's like a game of
telephon nothing like what I taught uh
so I think what's missing is like a
group of gurus that people can trust and
rely on and so we're launching a
newsletter it's called steal our winners
and I'm going to all of my like past
clients uh in addition to you know some
of the best today and asking them to so
we have about 50 different contributors
asking them to only contribute two three
times a year when they have something
that's really powerful a strategy or
tactic that will get a result and so our
belief is is that that's severely
missing in internet marketing today uh
we're going to be pricing it at an
insanely inexpensive price for internet
marketing by pricing it like every other
Agora publication so it'll be $49 a year
and it will have most if not all of the
big names in internet marketing like
Russell Brunson from clickfunnels has
already signed on board Brian dice from
digital marketer has already signed on
board Neil Patel is already so James
onon elswick who's one of the top media
buyers is like contributing so I've I've
gathered about 50 of these people men
and women who are the best in their
field in internet marketing I don't
think I only I could do it because I
have those relationships but even on my
own I couldn't do it because like they
also I have the relationships but
everyone has confidence in Agora and
agora's ability to acquire customers at
a loss and have the bank role to be able
to like keep that going um gives the
gurus confidence that like they're going
to get the exposure that they want from
something like this so we've got this
really special event planned on February
26th I don't know whether people will
see this before or after if they see it
after they'll certainly have heard about
it um my goal is to saturate the
internet that day so that no matter
where you are you will know about it and
I'm pretty confident that that will
happen and if it's before just keep your
eyes open because uh you're going to
come across it and just along those
lines like not to go any further on that
uh I think that point though about
different is better than better is so
important so I just want to stress that
to people like every single time I've
done a campaign I've always tried to
start it with something different than
what everyone is used to to grab
attention you know I wrote two of the
reports that I wrote in that series of
eight reports were about attention uh in
2007 I wrote the attention age Doctrine
one and two and and the first one was
all about how attention was going to
become the scarcest commodity online yes
and it has and then uh and and that
report was more about like how do you
maximize the payoff of your own
attention like you know I've got a
million things always trying to get my
attention from my kids to my boss to my
friends to my girlfriend to you know
everything right so how do I manage my
attention so I maximize the payoff and
then the second report was well where's
all this attention going and in that
report uh I predicted liiz of social
media so Facebook didn't exist yet but
Twitter had just come out and uh so I
was talking about that social media is
going to be the place and so I've always
tried to make myself stand apart and one
of the ways is a thought process that I
think the world is a bunch of marathon
runners I'm a sprinter I'm not like so
I'm going to get off the Starting Gate
I'm going to get way ahead of those
people right and then I'm going to make
my Splash I'm going to do my campaign
and then I'm going to
recede and Rec recuperate and recover
right so I've done things like you know
I did a 26h hour live stream back in
October of 2008 I'm proud that we beat
not that I had anything against the guy
but we beat John McCain on his live
stream and that was during the 2008
election in October um and you know from
the reports I write to just anything
that I can do that has me be different
right so you know I can promise anyone
who watches this if it's before February
26 look for something that's totally
different if it's after February 26 you
already know what I'm talking about
hopefully um but yeah different is
better than better and that's a hard
thing for people to really digest they
always want to think better is better
than better but better is subjective and
it's not easy to spot I I got it the
second you said it so if they if they
know the game that they're playing if
they go about it by leveraging a
strength or core capacity that they have
create an offer around it try and be
different in some way shape or form
deliver it as a service uh those are the
most General but always applicable
pieces of advice I could give I mean we
could dive into the weeds but I think
then we'll be only talking to a few
people whereas those things are
consistent everywhere I go even
companies like agore their strength up
to this point has been great copy right
part of my role here is to help them get
better at marketing because marketing
has become a lot more important in the
last five years years um so yeah it's
it's they only had to be good at one
thing and they were able to build a $
1.5 billion company right like I only
had to be good at business coaching I
was able to build a sizable company
right so better to be narrow and focused
but something that you love doing that
like others would hate doing um is ideal
right so I can talk business obviously
for 50 hours a week
non-stop um based on coaching I did but
to me that was fun that was not a grind
I didn't wake up every morning be like
oh my God right um if it was a grind I
wouldn't have been passionate I wouldn't
have been successful so it's about
finding your spot and I really do
believe like based on tens of thousands
of entrepreneurs I've worked with that
there is a spot for everyone it's just
not always easy to find but if they keep
looking backwards trying and see how
these dots connected to them where they
are today um they can figure it out it
just might take time well I'm great ful
you found your spot you've had an impact
on my life and thank you for being here
my
[Music]
pleasure next up we have burn Harish
author of scaling up and founder of
entrepreneur organization Verns helped
thousands and thousands of entrepreneurs
get their start and today he's going to
show you why hard work alone won't lead
to your wealth breakthrough oh he's also
going to share what he learned from
Steve Jobs
enjoy Vern I've heard about you for
years from the people I respect most in
the world especially in the world of
entrepreneurism so uh so I was really
really excited to come have this
interview so thanks for taking the time
to sit well Pat that's so nice to say
thank you appreciate it so let's start
just with your background like how did
you get started in all this well I grew
up around entrepreneur Ur So my
grandparents had their own companies my
grandmother literally Pat worked her
finger to the bone in in putting
together a poolery business uh my
grandfather was early on in the
television business and so he did a
television installation and repair and
appliance repair and Kinsley Kansas of
all places and and then my dad after he
left the military he they were literally
rocket engineers at Martin Marietta for
the Titan program Titan missile program
and so four of them as as no wer has
talked about at Harvard the best thing
to do is take an intact team and leave
and launch a company MH so they did
company called hire electronics and it
was a rocket ship and they were actually
installing uh television stations and
security systems for the wealthy and for
companies and then the 73 recession got
them and they got one of their customers
owed him about a half a million dollars
and the SEC came in and shut him down
and lo froze up his funds later on they
found he did nothing wrong but if all of
a sudden your major customer owes you a
half a million in cash flow back in the
late 60s when you're really trying to
scale uh the guys didn't believe in
bankruptcy back then so we began selling
off every asset that we had you know the
the homes the mountain property the toys
and everything trying to save the
business but ultimately couldn't W and
uh dad never recovered from that we
ended up that's when we moved from this
kind of beautiful place Colorado out to
Kinsley Kansas and he and I had to start
over appliance repair business uh but he
never recovered became an
alcoholic um ultim my
sisters uh felt the need to have him put
in jail because they were worried that
he was going to drink and drive and and
hurt somebody and they you know none of
us wanted that on our conscious and he
never really forgave us for that which
we get as well and and a few years ago
he passed away uh alone
and really really have been dedicated my
entire life to see if I can help every
entrepreneur not go through that and
every entrepreneurial family not go
through what I saw him and our family
have to experience through that kind of
failure so it's a very it's a very
missional thing for me Pat I could see
that and you know the experiences I mean
I I could feel in my chest as you're
talking about this because so often
people talk about you know great success
stories and and you know and these use
cases about people like like as this one
started out right group of guys come out
take to rocket ship but now there's
there's kind of the the segue from not
only oh the business thing what went
wrong what can we learn this business
failed the recession hit maybe they
didn't build their balance sheet strong
enough or you know something that that
made them vulnerable to such an event
and we could talk about that stuff but
what you spoke about is the human factor
saying you know this is a person that
was smart driven successful yes that
couldn't recover from something and I'm
sure there's other um uh hazards in here
that people can learn from like saying
hey bankruptcy maybe should be an option
as compared to saying that you destroy
your entire net worth you know when when
these types of things happen and you
know that that's a whole other
conversation but man you know looking at
years and Decades of your own personal
relationship and what had to happen as a
consequence uh there's a very human and
maybe somewhat spiritual side to this
entrepreneur thing isn't there there is
and you know one of the things we've
been really opening up and discussing
more is
uh entrepreneurs and leaders of these
growth companies they have one of the
highest cohorts of depression you know
the the pressures I don't think a lot of
people appreciate the pressures that
they carry particularly when you start
getting a group of employees and those
employees are you know have have
mortgages and car loans and if you mess
up it's not just you but you're you
could be taken down a whole lot of other
people now with unemployment the way it
is it's a little bit less risky but
still it's quite disruptive if you're
you're not going to continue to scale
your business successfully and it truly
is Pat Lonely at the Top and why I
founded the young entrepreneurs
organization which is EO today it it was
a good buddy of mine uh Joe manzu a
found of the CEO clubs who who said
early on it's it's okay to be
independent but no reason to be
alone and it's interesting right now
there's a new book that's going to be
coming out about
loneliness and particularly I have men
in the United States uh suffer it deeply
and so I think if there's been any
Legacy of EO it's the fact that every
one of these 14,000 entrepreneurs is in
a forum with six or seven or eight other
entrepreneurs so they don't feel alone
and I hate to be maybe this grotesque
about it but if they pass away they'll
at least be the Paul bearers right you
know and I ask men all right who would
be your pole bearers and they're like
well I'm not sure he'd be available
he'll probably be traveling not sure he
is that close to me it's uh this
loneliness thing is real yeah and so uh
and I saw my dad go through it and so
anyway if nothing else I think we've
left a legacy of process where these
entrepreneurs are not alone that are
part of
B really can relate to that on a deep
and personal level as a matter of fact
the first time I heard about you was uh
because I was in uh you I guess what was
a former an accountability group with
other business owners and entrepreneurs
and uh you I met one of your friends
Rick sappio who uh you know couldn't
stop saying enough great things about
you and you so I started reading your
books learning your principles and
incidentally you so you're looking at
somebody who's been greatly helped by
your work who you never met I'm another
one of those you've got a lot of those
but I'm just another one and it's so
enriching for me uh to hear you talk
about you know the the psycho emotional
side of of entrepreneurism and success
you know you can say Hey you know it's
it's kind of depressing to fail but when
you're very successful too and you're
the guy who had to make the gal had to
make the hard decisions and you're kind
of sitting in this place and you know
you're you're responsible for all these
houses mortgages car payments of the
people that work for you um yeah that's
another form of Lon loneliness too so
it's really interesting to hear you talk
about that when did you form uh young
entrepreneurs organization yeah so uh
the official start dat was 1987 but the
impetus pad was I had this opportunity
to host the first public speech of Steve
Jobs after he was fired from Apple wow
and I knew his PR guy Danel Luen and
several other folks and Regis McKenna uh
team had been a had been consultants and
coaches to me and through all of that
after he had been fired in 85 I'd put
out this list called The ace1 100 what
are the top 100 young entrepreneurs
under the age of 30 right and since he
was still in that leadership position 85
when we did the event in ' 86 we're like
look Steve he literally distorted the
list a lot of people don't appreciate
that at the time 29 Bill Gates By the
way the same age uh on that list Steve
was at 1.9 billion wow in Revenue I mean
he really was the first true young
entrepreneur bill was number four on the
list at a poultry 256 million and so a
lot of folks don't appreciate but Steve
had scaled in his 20s a company 8X wow
that of what Bill Gates had same age uh
at Microsoft and so we got him out to
The Bonaventure Hotel in LA and I'm
telling you you could hear a pin drop in
that room of almost 1,200 young
entrepreneurs I had sitting up there
with Steve Young Michael Dal and Mark
Cuban and Kevin har Neil Balter
California Closets all these young hot
shots in their 20s and afterwards I
threw a party for the Ace 100 winners
and I remember being up there and Steve
literally was standing in the corner by
himself and I remember
uh this young woman entrepreneur out of
Chicago going and asking uh Steve out on
the dance floor to dance and he did uh
but I realized wow this Joe makuza is
right it's okay to be independent but no
reason to be alone I turn to my buddy
Greg Stam who's the great treasure
hunter and I said great we we have to
form an organization for for Steve and
and people like Steve and so it was that
night that the idea for the young
entrepreneurs organization was bir it
took me a year get the money raise get
everything in place so we launched
officially in 1987 wow how many members
now uh 14,000 on the way to 28,000 we've
hit our inflection point wow uh like we
teach you know organizations to at their
25th anniversary That's so exciting so
you know as I look and and as I hear you
reminisce about back then and you know
I'm loving the creativity of of how you
were seeing things and what you were
putting together and creating
experiences for other entrepreneurs
which uh you know is just invaluable uh
but when you now cuz you've got you know
some some years of of experience and
looking back and you were around you
know for you know around a lot of really
influential entrepreneurs and you're one
yourself um that did things to this
point at least is it kind of as you
expected or is this like wildly
different than what you were thinking in
your 20s as far as what your career
would be um well look I thought I was
going to be in the Nuclear Navy so I'm
the mechanical engineer by training I uh
was prly working in the nuclear field
and I was getting ready to be uh Admiral
rickover's very last class we I would
have known at the time to be chosen and
then I was plucked out of that and asked
to help kind of scale a center for
entrepreneurship at my alma Mo which St
State University and the rest's history
so uh and we like to talk about I'm
reading a great book right now called
greatness cannot be
planned and you know we we've got to set
priorities on a daily weekly basis but
you ask anyone what they're doing today
was is really their plan uh it's more
about serendipity and letting the love
flow and that's what happened uh never
would have guessed it now when I
launched yo absolutely it was always
meant to be the YPO for entrepreneurs
and YP already had massive scale pths so
uh I could see it and it that vision is
being realized here you know three
decades later it seems like to a large
degree you your career is kind of like a
Magic Carpet Ride you know kind of LED
you to places I know you lived in Europe
for a while Etc so really really
interesting so with people you know the
person that's watching us right now who
has such an interest in in you know
business and being an entrepreneur uh
what are some of the foundations that
you think are the cornerstones of your
philosophy around business and how to
become successful in business well it's
not follow your passion okay you know
everyone's saying you know follow your
passion and it's like 99% of the people
people on planet have no idea what their
passion is and honestly Steve Jobs did
not have a passion he didn't sit around
and say oh I want to build the largest
computer company in the world no what
happens and there was a great
entrepreneurship Professor Ron ronad
that called it the corridor principal
you just start working you just start
doing things and all of a sudden you
bump into something that you're either
really good at or starts to become
successful and then that becomes your
passion
so it's reversing cause and effect it
really is and by the way I'd love to
take credit for this but this is Cal
Newport you know I think he's one of the
bright thinkers of this new
generation of thought leaders and Cal's
the one who was the first to say look
you got we got to take this whole
passion thing off the table and instead
just start working and then when things
start working out then all of a sudden
you become passionate I guarantee you if
those first computers were rejected and
there were a lot of people who had
launched similar things and like Adam
Osborne that it didn't work out I
guarantee you Steve Jobs wouldn't have
been passionate about he would have
found something that he was now I don't
know that personally but uh I haven't
read anything where he was like 12
saying oh my gosh I would love to bring
computers to the world is there an
integration uh aspect of this where once
you find something that you're good at
and I think timing has a lot to do with
it right it's like you know what was the
world doing when you know he stumbled
across Compu computers and
microelectronics and all this kind of
stuff you know I think uh there is a
certain lack of a better term luck and
timing saying hey you where you are
what's going on in the world these
things kind of there's a Confluence but
but jobs also had a a passion around art
and and somehow started to apply that
passion to the way he was going to
develop these computers so do you see
kind of an intersection of those things
yeah I and I think it is luck it is
Serendipity yeah uh which is what this
book greatness cannot be planned really
emphasizes and you're absolutely right
about Market timing uh you know we talk
about in our book that there are four
components people strategy execution and
cash and and the question always is
which one of those is more important so
Bill gross at ID lab said all right I
want to look at kind of the 100
companies that we've launched and the
other 100 companies that maybe he's
helped fund and he wanted to see what
was the key to those who made it and
those companies that didn't and he
really looked at the equivalent of kind
of people strategy execution cach and I
loved Pat that there were two really
unique conclusions that came out of that
number one all four matter equally it's
like a table with four legs if you're
missing one of them it's just not going
to be a stable but he found a fifth that
trumped them all I even went back and
re-edited my book Because I had missed
that and it was Market timing ah the
market either makes you look smart or
makes you look stupid right and it's
stupid to fight the win of the
marketplace they had Bill talked about
how they had funded a company that
should have been YouTube but they were
too early there was it wasn't easy to
make videos on your phones and upload
them and edit them and all of that and
the bandwidth wasn't there so the timing
wasn't right so if nothing else uh all
of a sudden you find that you're good at
it which then you become passionate
about maybe what you have to do is hold
out until Bell Bottom Jeans come back in
the fashion right and then you can you
can ride the the wave but man if you
missed the wave you probably ought pivot
you know it's interesting uh you as
you're saying this cuz I'm cringing in
my own experiences cuz I had uh um a lot
of Healthcare in my background and
wellness on the wellness side of it and
you lifestyle wellness and Longevity
that kind of stuff so uh we had uh
launched a a wellness company I mean we
got 30 patents we had you know really
put together good technology we were and
uh and it got traction but we were
really just for the technology and what
we're trying to accomplish we're a
little bit early and uh and so it was
real struggled for a long time and never
really got to the vision that we wanted
for it and uh and so and as many
entrepreneurs will say oh you know it's
right I was just early you know and I
have a really good friend who was a top
Wall Street analyst and then became a
very very successful entrepreneur um and
he looked at me and he said well you
know what they say on Wall Street I said
what he said being early and being wrong
is the same thing yeah exactly that's
really what this is right well and on
the flip side my favorite quote of
Steve's almost of all time jobs was you
know I'm always amazed how overnight
successes take a hell of a long time and
even though he had that early success in
his 20s it then was a disaster and it
wasn't until the 25th anniversary of
Apple did it really hit its inflection
point wow uh Starbucks was the same way
it took 20 years for them to get their
first hundred stores and it wasn't
really till their 25th anniversary that
they hit the inflection point now we
talk a lot about how come the unicorns
are able to do it at about half the time
it still takes them about a decade and
we've now learned a couple of things
that they do which we can talk about but
it takes time let's so let's talk about
that uh so what uh what are some of the
things they can do or you know
accelerate to the inflection point and
you I'd love to hear some of your
examples of this yeah so one of the
thing there's two things that the
unicorns do that us mere mortal Business
Leaders can adopt accelerate our scaling
the first is and it's a it's the most
significant back to Trends most
significant Trend in the history of
business happened in 2007 and it and the
financial crisis was just a result of
this change for hundreds of years we had
more demand than Supply and so really if
you could just show up if you had the
minerals and the resources if you had
what I needed you know you could you
could scale the company and we spent
particularly the last 50 years running
around the planet trying to figure out
how to do it better faster cheaper it
was all about Supply Chain management it
was all about cost MH but with the mid
middle class coming on strong this
Century it's overd doubled in just 20
years um you would think there'd be more
demand but those people have to supply
before they can consume and so in 2007
this is Rick Cash's work at uh the
demand
Institute overnight there is now more
Supply MH than there is demand in every
single industry and with the internet
being able now to do business with
anyone anywhere at any time in any way
uh we've got Global competition look the
United States is now a net energy
exporter which is why the Middle East is
you know pivoting to entertainment
instead of uh the oil industry and so
what has to happen is all the unicorns
pad all the unicorns Supply nothing
they're all on the demand side of the
equation you've got to the leaders of
companies now have to understand the
market like they understood the cost
side or supply side of the business what
does that mean very practically you got
to get your head out of the cost side
and get your head into the price side uh
and we almost all mess up price because
we're selling to people who are not
logical they're psychological so think
about it all the unicorns how often does
price change on Amazon how does Uber
price how do all of those how do the
airlines now price it's based on a deep
understanding of the demand side of the
business knowing where the customer just
went will get you to the concert cheap
but you're going to pay a fortune to get
home kind of thing whereas the taxi cap
companies charging the same you know
cost per eighth of a mile and that
retailers has one sticker price where
Amazon's changing the price almost every
hour based on theand so number one all
all the unicorns got there because they
understand the market and the demand and
the customer side and they don't Supply
anything the second thing that all the
unicorns have figured out and I call it
most brains how to get the most free
labor on the planet so if you think
about uh let's go back to Amazon what
how does Amazon really have value in the
marketplace why it's now the number one
product search engine millions of
reviews over 500 just for my book and
what did Amazon pay all those millions
of people to review those products zero
if you look at Wikipedia 300,000
volunteers on average eight hours a day
uh keeping Wikipedia up today what have
they paid those people zero if you look
at Google hey what I'm I'm going to
search for something I need an answer
they don't have really high paid people
typing fast yeah maybe building the
technology but they have 3.2 billion
people that have been on the internet
they're scour ing their votes and
delivering up in nanoseconds what they
think is the best answer all the
unicorns pad Facebook its valuation is
tied to number of users over two billion
what do they what's Facebook paying all
of us to keep our Facebook pages up to
date minute by minute zero if you've got
two billion free
employees you can pay your tens of
thousands a lot of money and so we're
teaching us m
how to get focused on the demand side as
much as on the supply side and how to
begin to involve the crowd in scaling
your business because if you can get the
most brains engaged you win these are
really brilliant insights I mean I'm
always studying these things I'm reading
the books but you're putting it into
context and the light bulbs are popping
in my head right now which is really
really great you're looking at you know
Supply and understanding like yeah
Airbnb and Uber and LIF what what
they're really doing and how they have
huge valuations when they don't really
own anything right they don't Supply the
room they connect people you have rooms
the Airbnb for example so I so get that
the price thing is also really really
fascinating uh a friend of mine um that
I spent a lot of time talking to is an
economist who was in one of our docu
series his name is Paul Zan pser and and
Paul one time sent me he was overly
excited and and so I'd like to talk
about this just set it up he was overly
excited it was a scholarly economics
paper was about 50 pages on what they
called consumer elasticity meaning that
in the past if if you're the supplier
and you wanted to sell something you
sold something for $9 but the consumer
really would have paid $10 for it you
left a dollar on the table did but there
was no way to really know um you know
what that consumer eless is you'd
speculate you'd study you maybe test but
he said now with like uber uh you know
they can test say oh it's going to be 2x
because of the demand or 3x you know
Amazon the they have so much data flow
that they can literally know the
consumer elasticity in real time and
then price according so so I I think
that mastering for businesses now
mastering your pricing probably is a
really important thing to do what's what
advice so if I'm the entrepreneur and
I've got a company you know whatever
scale you can make up scales you know
$10 million company let's say and uh and
I'm confused about our pricing and not
sure if I'm doing it right um you know
what what should I be thinking about and
how would I try to get this right yeah
so first start uh paying attention to it
and learn about it you know most folk
entrepreneurs I talked about haven't
taken a single course or read a single
book on pricing so start with guilty is
charged on that incidentally so start
with the book confessions of a pricing
Man by Herman Simon Herman is the guru
of pricing he runs the largest pricing
consultancy in the world uh almost 300
million
he'll do this year just in pricing
consultancy and he was an advisor uh is
an adviser to our company number two
there's and I want to share just a
couple very practical examples that
might illustrate this so the Godfather
of influence Robert chalini did um this
interesting piece of research and
discovered that let's just take a wine
list at a
restaurant and most of the wine lists
are ordered from least expensive wine to
most expensive wine correct all you have
to do is reverse the list and put the
most expensive at top to the least
expensive you didn't change a bottle you
didn't change a price you'll drive about
26% more Revenue just from the order
just by from the order because remember
people are not logical they're
psychological this is why we get price
so wrong then if you anchor that wine
list with two or three super expensive
bottles of wine you'll pull Revenue up
almost
250% so to with 250 on the same list
same inventory same inventory how how
you present it so I am in shangai a few
months ago where we finally launched our
book in Mandarin and and one of the YPO
guys are Adrien wall by the way it's got
a fantastic business which book because
you have a few uh scaling up scaling up
some my laest book scaling up we finally
got it Mandarin um and so Adrien wall
who's got this spectacular fun business
he calls it a taste of New York in high
so what he's done he's gone to New York
to these iconic brands starting with
Joe's Pizza anyone who's in New York
City knows about the famous Joe's Pizza
and he arranges with each of these
families to bring their brand to China
and so he was in my workshop about a
year ago when I'm talking about this
pricing so let's speed up a year later
he's hosting me for this event he said
ver you've got to come to my one of my
pizza restaurants so he comes over and
he says Vern you got to see what we did
up on the big screen is his pricing list
he said we used to list the price from
least his vegan to his most expensive
meat lovers said Vern all I did was
after your Workshop reverse the list and
we didn't get the 26% but we got almost
16% bump in Revenue just by reversing
the order of the pizzas from most to
leas instead of leaste to most so so
it's that kind of
Simplicity um I'll give you a business a
couple business visit examples so I was
invited back uh to this executive
program that I found and still get to
teach in I I got invited back to the the
Titans program that Rick sappio is part
of a couple years ago and I mentioned
this pricing thing and one of the guys
says ver I know exactly what you're
talking about I've got this killer
software solution for the Fortune 500
but and it's like only $2500 a month 30
grand a year and we haven't been able to
sell a one so I said look I'm going to
go out and talk to the customers myself
and so he goes out and says look you
guys have this huge problem they're like
we know and he says and I think we've
got this beautifully elegant solution
and they're like it appears that you do
so he's like so why aren't you buying
the product and literally the customer's
like cuz it's only 30,000 do you know
what it's going to cost for us to
implement this it's magnitudes more and
at 30 grand we don't trust that you can
really solve this multi-million dollar
problem that we have for that and I'm
not we're not sure you're still going to
be around to support it and then
somewhere in one of those conversations
one of the guys intimated that you know
we got like
10x what your software cost budgeted to
fix this problem and so it didn't take
him long to clue in and he literally Pat
10x the price of his offering from 30
grand a year to
3,000 and now he can't service them as
quick as they're flying off the shell
kid cuz
price as the subtitle of this book I
recommend it says price affects
everything and so quality is is signaled
Often by the price and that's what he
learned so in a real businesso business
situation and we're huge fans of
Victoria Med Beck the negotiations
professor at Northwestern University uh
if you're in a competitive bid situation
businesses to business even if it's a
client that you've had for years and now
it's come up for rebit you always submit
three proposals a good better best and
about a year ago in Harvard Business
Review they did a major in-depth article
about how companies are going back to
the good better best pricing uh and as a
result Dell EMC for instance you know
Michael's now back public they were able
to triple triple the amount of after
service Revenue they could generate
after selling their software package by
going to a good better best three
offerings then instead of one single
price so look I I could spend hours and
you need to spend hours but the
psychology around pricing is something
that we've got to better understand
which we can as mere mortals and as you
just said if you can take it if you can
add a dollar to the price generally it
goes right to the bottom line right and
if you're at a 10% profitability you got
to generate 10 more Dollar in Revenue to
get that same to the bottom line you
know I'm I'm sitting here in stunned uh
you know disbelief in the sense that
everything you just said is
counterintuitive and counter to what you
know many uh Consultants have told me
because what do most people do they're
like put your lowest price up first
right and you so that people say oh I
can that's the entry point and then try
to upsell or try to add you know stack
more value to the other you know offers
that bring them maybe to your higher
offer but everything you just said is
the opposite of that uh you know
basically saying hey uh you start with
the most expensive bottle of wine and
make them work down so it's it's like
you know wow first of all then then
secondly what I just heard is you've got
a company that was struggling with a
$30,000 price point on a product and
most people would say well if they're
not buying it maybe we got to try to
even lower the price more because
they're saying what's the cheapest we
can get to Market with to get people to
want thinking that low price is what
attractive for most people and now they
10x their price and go for maybe they're
not going to make it it and their only
problem was a pricing problem maybe
they're not going to make it to now
they're soaring uh you know this is
stunning information yeah so uh and and
you write about this in scaling I do
we're really digging into this and and
part of its Pat and and I love I think
it's one of the best book titles and
that's Marshall gold smith what got you
here won't get you there but it's it's
real M um the biggest if if we were to
boil down to one thing the biggest
constraint of entrepreneur scaling is
everything that they did to get launched
will now cause them to fail and it's
this inability to be able to let go so
for instance pricing most entrepreneurs
got into a market by hey we're just
going to do it cheaper and get our foot
in the door just as you described but if
you don't let go of that mental when you
hit the the scale you're not going to
have the resources you need in order to
to fuel the business in the very
beginning you said yes to whoever would
talk to you partner with you willing to
have coffee with you now you better be
saying no 20 times more than you said
yes and in the beginning you answered
everyone's questions anyone who came
into your office called you up emailed
you hey what should we do you needed
answers when you scaled when you started
but once you hit scale you better be
answering nobody's questions because if
you do then all they're going to do is
keep coming to ask you and you can never
get freed uh up as the leader in order
to do the things you need to do in order
to scale the business so and coming back
again to price the problem is once
you're in the market scaling you're
going to be competing with these new
entrepreneurs that don't want to low
ball it and get in there and that's why
your pricing strategy when you go into
these competitive situations is
Paramount and how you handle it yeah I
mean this rings so true to my my
personal experience I had a diagnostic
technology company some years ago and uh
and we were trying to figure out scaling
and I was pumping you know just kept
hitting my head on a ceiling and a
consultant basically looked at me and I
was the founder and said you know the
founder strength is the company's
weakness yeah and and and so exactly
what you're talking about is you know I
can I can validate it through my own
experience with this I wish I'd had this
conversation with you maybe about 20
years ago go well that's why we're doing
this so we can help others yeah I mean
it's it's really amazing now you seem
really energized it's I mean you you
come to life uh and you know the energy
is is is visible you talk about these
things how is it after all these years
spending all this time in this space
thinking about and talking about the
things you do how does it still excite
you to this level um you know because
I'm lucky Pat I hear literally from
entrepreneurs every day m
and we've touched about 70,000 now
around the world with our tools and so
the odds are and every one day any one
day I'm going to hear from what I'm say
ver I just got to tell you I've never
met you but I've been using your tools
and ideas and reading your weekly
insights and our company's gone from
here to here and all the kind of things
that I wanted for my dad uh I'm seeing
now happen in all these other company so
why wouldn't you absolutely be energized
and this is a key I think for for uh for
for people as they going through phases
of of life and experience you're not
giving the same talks today that you did
10 years ago or 20 years you like a lot
of times I'm the next week I will not
give the same talk next week part of the
problem I I wish I had a canned speech
that I could get on stage and give but
but it also is is the you know staying
current and relevant thing right I mean
because so often you there's so many um
you know entrepreneur uh you know
thought leaders ex so on that you know
I've seen speak 25 years ago and there
they are giving that same talk again
today but what I'm seeing in your books
and and what you're talking about is
that there's new information here now we
got to focus on priceing now we're going
to talk about you know how this had
Chang Etc and so how is it that you stay
current how is it that your thinking
keeps advancing because the world is
changing faster at you at a faster Pace
than it ever has and I believe it
becomes bewildering especially for guys
like me who started companies in the 80s
right and now you know it's a different
deal now and it be can become be
wildering because you have old
foundations that you work from how do
you separate because I still think
Rockefeller principles still apply I
mean there there's there's foundational
things that will never change no matter
what's going on in the world I think at
least and you could tell me if you agree
with this and then there's current
understanding that you have to have that
that must be matched to it so can you
speak that a little bit Yeah well I
think you know I thought Jim Collins had
a beautiful framework around that the
yin and the Yang of preserve the core
right and there are there are these
foundational principles what are your
priorities what's the data metrics and
the meeting Rhythm communication around
that that is never going to change uh
but then he had stimulate progress and
that's the stuff that can change
overnight with a new technology and A
disruption in the industry by a
competitor so you've got to be playing
both sides of that equation and I think
you absolutely right the word is
relevant how do you as a leader remain
relevant and how do you keep your
company products and services relevant
mhm and that's where to me the role
model for that Bill Gates and I think
it's one of the reasons why I think it's
crazy that it's both apple and Microsoft
two of the oldest technology companies
that are the two largest market cap
companies right now over a trillion
right beating All the Young Guns right
the Amazon and the Google alphabets and
Facebooks and all that kind of stuff and
part of that I equate back and I
featured him in my my second book
greatest business decisions was Bill
Gates think week you know we all have
what I call this Tower of guilt you know
every day Pat somebody's like hey ver
you got a moment take a look at this
tribute to Clayton Christensen who just
passed away uh this week and watch this
YouTube video and take a look at this
new book and it just piles up and so
Bill had no it's same situation so twice
a year he would take his record was 112
books manuscripts PhD thesis white
papers and for 18 hours a day seven days
straight he would just Pile in that
information and he got in the flow with
it and he could begin to see the
patterns and Trends and out of that were
the handful of ideas you only need to
make one or two great decisions that
have kept him and Microsoft relevant I I
didn't know i' I know Mark hban since
his second year in business when he had
little IT services company in Dallas but
I didn't know till I read his book and
saw him years later he is had a habit of
reading for 3 hours every single day
it's that idea if you want to be an
Olympic Athlete you've got to train for
three hours and since we're in the brain
business you you need to be training the
brain yeah uh and that's where he gets
his goal just one idea every single day
to help one of the 150 plus companies
either owns or invest Warren Buffett uh
on their 50th Anniversary uh they asked
Charlie amer's partner all right how's
Warren dun it how how is he beat the
market by a factor of 10 for five
decades and it was interesting Charlie
didn't hesitate a moment he goes it's
been Warren's first priority to reserve
quote much time for quiet reading and
thinking even at his Advanced age and so
he's consuming the headlines of 50
newspapers every day looking for those
patterns and Trends in the marketplace
where he's then able to place just one
or two bets Maybe a year so how's it
done in a practical sense I I have a
piece of paper every week uh and as
people send me hey when you have a
chance watch this YouTube video read
this article scan through this book I
park it on this one document and then
every Thursday I take three hours and
that's when I write my weekly insights
and I give myself permission to watch
that 4minute video to read through that
article to take a look at this new book
that's just been sent to me and and then
I synthesize it into some ideas that I
share one of the best ways to learn is
to teach right and so I have this gift
of some quiet reading and thinking time
every single week which we think by the
way Pat is probably one of the top five
most important measurable things I'm
writing a new book about what should
leaders of growth companies really
measurably be doing every day with their
minutes and hours and this is one of
them well you know you're talking about
habits you know rock habits these are
certain habits they had so these are uh
individual habits for you know the
leader or the person and then I think
the company probably has to have some
habits also so can you talk about habits
and their role in the life of of a of
the business leader and the company as
an organism yeah because you know what
comes down to success is just the sum
total of all the things you do more of
less of or different every day that
that's just it whether it's your
personal or Company Success so are you
meditating every day I mean the research
around that is absolutely clear
hopefully if you're not meditating
you're not optimizing this very
important competitive weapon in the
information age um you know what are you
doing to exercise are you eating
correctly so there's a lot of you know
very personal the Gratitude Journal kind
of exercise that we know our hands down
just non-starters if you're not doing
them you're you're really
uh not maximizing your opportunities and
then we've got some of the equivalent
ones inside the company the thing we're
best known for this daily huddle this 10
to 15 minutes that if you do it right
each minute the people are in that
huddle will save them 10 minutes so if
it's I was just a steel case they have a
7 minute
huddle every morning at 9:00 another one
at 300 p.m. at sift change and if you do
it right that 7 minutes will save
everybody over an hour 10 to one return
it it is the it's the ROI that that you
need within the organization so it's
those that we detail in first my
original book and then in in scaling up
you know it's interesting because you're
I feel like wow okay this is validating
for me um we just went away we do a
company Retreat every year uh and we
just for revealed films this company we
went away to Hawaii to really talk about
the revisit everything Etc you got to
get into a different environment so we
live in the mountains and the snow in
the winter so it's good to get to the
beach in the Sun and think creatively uh
but one of the things for me personally
I said okay I'm changing my morning
routine and and there the three phases
it's going to be
meditate uh orchestrate and then
recreate so B and I start with so it's
exactly that thing I've got a pretty
strong meditation practice so meditate
first that's the first thing I'm going
to do in the morning then orchestrate go
and orchestrate this day and how it has
to happen you have spend the time
quietly you you know doing that and then
recreate go exercise you know do do your
exercise routine so uh so it sounds like
I picked the right habits in the right
morning based on what you're just saying
you did and I I don't think people have
to get stuck in the order or sequence
but all the research is really clear the
folks that have achieved the most by the
way only work intensely deep work for 90
minutes to three hours a day interesting
you know it's it's Richard Branson who
really puts in a very strong morning
there at neker Island and then business
is off limits really the rest of the day
you they're really learning that you
then need to actually get away you can't
be just Lolly gagging around an email
and all that cuz it just destroys your
energy and your your brain power so
you've got the sequence right you know
get the right start get some deep work
and then go have fun so if for somebody
watching right now if they're an
entrepreneur and they're putting in 10
hard hours a day and they're sometimes
working weekends do they need a course
correction right now they do and in fact
one of the opening chapters in scaling
up is about Allan Rudy you know when I
met him Allan was working 80h hour weeks
you know building a company called in
the medical field out of uh Columbus
Ohio of all places and when he we
finished with him he was able to get all
that done in eight hours we now it
doesn't mean you're not doing stuff the
other rest of the week we we're really
adamant you ought to be out doing Market
facing activities that demand side where
you're talking to customers employees
and shopping competitors but we're
adamant you should be a able to run the
business a day a week can you give me a
couple of examples of what you found
with him how you got him from 80 to 8
well first one was the meeting Rhythm so
we're really adamant that a lot of time
the mistake entrepreneurs make is
they'll spread out their various
operating meetings throughout the week
so Mondays ex leadership team and then
Tuesdays the sales meeting and then
Wednesdays the marketing meeting and
Friday's the accounting meeting and I
learned it from Rick K one of my early
uh client clients who would put them all
together on Monday morning so you could
get in the
flow and he got in a series of five
hours everything decided that needed to
be done the Sprints that everyone on his
team were going to run for the rest of
the week so then he could leave at noon
he and his team could leave at noon and
go out in the marketplace the rest of
the week and Allen was able to do the
same thing number two their only touch
point was the daily huddle and again if
that's going to give you huge Leverage
and you can get a sense of what are the
headlines in my own company of what's
happening today then I know where to go
and where not to go with my activities
so the foundational was a good meeting
Rhythm number two make sure we're
measuring that which matters but
quantitative and qualitative and then
number three get on message figure out
not the 10 not the five but the one
priority for today this week this
quarter this year in the next 10 to 25
years and that's what that's what that
first chapter of the book details is how
we did that for alen yeah and you're
you're famous for you know the huddles
amongst many other things is start
saying how important it is more and more
companies are becoming more and more
virtual yes so how how are you applying
that principle to Virtual companies well
thank goodness we have cell phones you
know and zoom yeah you know now we don't
need to see each other's faces so we
don't use the video component but we all
have a URL it's right on my phone I can
push a button boom I'm in a zoom meeting
uh you know alarm goes off the daili and
minutes you're in the meeting uh quickly
and then it's done we're talking about a
restroom break and one of my favorite
stories so people are saying yeah but
you know especially as entrepreneurs
were in these critical meetings so I had
taken a couple about a year to get a
meeting with Tom Meredith who was
Michael Dell CFO and then was running
Dell Ventures and so I'm heading down
into Austin to meet with him and I and
once you know when your daily huddle is
you just everything just kind of forms
around it well I get a call from Tom's
office he needs to move my meeting up an
hour and it's going to be right when my
daily huddle I I never know what time
zone I'm going to be in so I'm getting
ready to go in the meeting and my phone
buzzes ah it's my daily so I jump in
Tom's like Vern good to meet you da d da
D and he said I hope it wouldn't come me
I had to move the meeting up I said Tom
I I I have this daily give me just one
second let me pop up tell the team
what's going on and let me come back in
Tom told me that that's one of the
reasons why you know we're great friends
today and we got to do some things
together is he said look anyone who's
that disciplined you know I want to do
business with right and I'm thinking I
need to set up a daily huddle in all my
sales calls just to kind of show off our
particular discipline and so uh really
there's no excuse uh and if you can get
done in seven minutes what going to take
you 70 it's it's worth the the tradeoff
can you give me the quick structure of
the seven minutes like you know is there
is there like like okay yeah there is
and um so it's three agend items uh
what's up so you want to go around and
you want to do three rounds cuz one of
the things that Google learned in terms
of the effectiveness of teams is equal
talk time it's it's a very simple thing
if you're in a meeting and three people
of the aid are doing all the Talking you
got a problem and so you've got to make
sure everyone's sharing so the idea of
the daily is to make sure that the the
eight people are each talking so first
you do a round of what's up in
particularly what's the most important
thing you're working on today and what
the leader thinking is like Jim mccan is
it going to sell more flowers you know
hey here's what I'm doing and you're
thinking but is that going to sell more
flowers and you can have that
conversation after so you get to see a
pattern of people's priorities to make
sure that they're focused on that that's
going to move the organization forward
these are the headlines the second
agenda item is kind of data and there's
something we're a the homo sapiens have
been around for about 200,000 years and
our goal obviously been to Survive and
Thrive and so we developed some tools
along the way to do that 100,000 years
ago we developed speech we've only had
the written word 5,000 years and we've
only had Excel spreadsheets for like 50
years so I know which one were more
highly developed in surviving and
thriving and that's talking sharing
stories and so what you're really doing
in that second round is you're saying
out loud the data you know what our
sales are open positions we've got
contracts we're working on on so that
everyone gets a gut feel for how the
business is doing and no one can say
nobody told me uh nobody you know didn't
you know no nobody didn't tell me this
so what's up any of the data metrics
that drive the business daily and then
number three is the most important
agenda item that is where are you
blocked where you where's the constraint
where are you stuck and it's not about
sharing what you think others can help
you with it's about most importantly you
verbalizing it we know the brain if you
sit around and think the mid is firing
fight flight freeze you know uh flock
women have a much you know better
response than men do um only when you
speak it Pat does your fight ORF flight
response shut down and you can begin
lighting up the prefrontal loes like a
Christmas tree so you can start to solve
it we're a being that needs to talk and
so by me putting out to the universe
verbally sending out the
vibrations what I need I why can't I get
this person to call back I can't seem to
get a signature on this contract I you I
can't move forward until Jerry's team
moves forward and you've all experienced
it the minute you I just had it happen
I'm interviewing somebody locally for
our chap marketing officer I had not
heard from her for two months her mother
had passed away she needed some time at
the end of the year and we're in our
strategic planning session two weeks ago
and that day her name came up hours
later a text comes in from her hey I was
just thinking about you today you've had
that experience right so many times I
can't count them and and we know it's
real you put out the vibrations and if
we can pick up Vikings weak signals at
the edges of our universe the rest of us
humans can pick up our verbalizations of
chres for help yeah which is really what
the stucks are so long answer to a short
question what's up quick round what's
the day to driving the business quick
round and number three where are we all
stuck or constrained and the idea is not
to try to solve the problem in that
meeting or it's going to go from 15
minutes to 50 and everyone's going to
hate you for it but it's to give you a
guidance of all right where might I Mo
most be most helpful to people the rest
of the day and that's the power of the
daily that's there's there's one thing
I'm wondering I'm sure you have some
rules around so you have extroverts in
the Huddle so what what is the rule
around saying hey I know maybe you'd
love to have a conversation right now
but we we literally are going to be done
in s minutes yeah um so do you tell them
it's a it's 10 seconds each each round
or how do you do that it is literally
it's it's usually averages a minute per
person so if I've got six it's six
minutes if I got 15 it's be 15 minutes
and it's 20 seconds for each of those
agenda items and the way you start is
you just have an timer at steel case
they have a big timer that at the end of
seven minutes these horns blare it's
almost scares you you're going to learn
very quickly to get to the point and
that's how you get the discipline in it
that's how you get the discipline but
also by going around yeah it's the
introverts and the women which the
research show typically don't have as
much opportunity to speak as the men do
the extroverted man so that's why it's
particularly important wow this is all
really fascinating stuff I feel like we
could do like 10 episodes with you
actually you know CU I'm sure we could
double click on any of these things and
go de so uh which is the virtue reading
your books so uh so anyway thank you so
much for sharing all this I just one
last question for you what are you most
excited about right now um we are
hitting our inflection point we hit our
20 you say we are you talking about
gazelle's or well we changed the name to
scaling up so we actually took the we we
realized what we uh we need to practice
what we preach we had a stupid name for
the company it worked for a while L's
but nobody could spell it as two Z's 12
L yeah an S at the end you know so we
we're all in with scaling up and that
term seems to have hit its stride in the
last 24 months and as we teach as well
we hit our 25th anniversary and so we're
ready we're ready to or we're
approaching our 25th anniversary we're
ready to hit the inflection point and
10x our influence out the marketplace
that's uh really exciting anyway and I
can see your excitement about it uh so
you're you're really energized so I'm
sure that's going to happen but uh you
really touched a lot of people here
sharing today and you gave very
graciously I mean you there's no holding
back I could tell that so thanks so much
for I know you're busy so thanks so much
for for taking the time to share with us
and I can speak personally I got a ton
out of this I can't wait to go back and
start making notes around what's in my
brain right now and I'm sure that
everybody that watched this did also so
thanks so much B I really appreciate it
you're welcome Pat
your episode 8 bonus interview comes
from Rick sapio a well-known
entrepreneur Rick wants to show you why
some people get ahead and why so many
others don't in 21st century America
knowing this one thing will change how
you approach success and wealth building
forever here's Rick watch this bonus
interview
[Music]
closely
Rick thanks for taking the time to sit
and have this conversation you're
welcome so uh let's talk about your
story because I think that really helped
to form a lot of your activities today
and and kind of your outcomes so talk
about your background yeah a lot of this
that I'm going to talk about is
relatively recent I would say the last
15 years-ish MH of my 56 years on the
planet and I have come to realize that
if somebody watching this has not done
the work to link what they've become as
an adult to what happened to them in
childhood if they haven't done that work
and you know uh dug really deep on it I
think that they're not going to have as
fulfilling of a life and it took a lot
of deep work for me to understand what
motivates me and I didn't
appreciate just how screwed up my
childhood was so uh my mother Marie she
wanted a big family and she's from hobok
New Jersey
Italian and um I ended up being the
seventh of 10 kids so she had 10 babies
and it's interesting uh in February of
1963 uh right right when she found out
that she was pregnant with me her
seventh
child at the exact same time she found
out that my 4-year-old brother was given
6 months to live so he had a rare form
of cancer which by the way was curable
two years later it's called Will's tumor
but the whole time she carried me she
was going back and forth uh to you know
chemotherapy and crying now if you think
about a four-year-old in your home he
was the king of the house he was the
light of her life he was everything and
I have a four-year-old at home right now
and I know what that's like just
imagine that and once she had that
diagnosis of Frankie her life changed
her her future was all uh nervous
breakdowns and in and- out of mental
institutions and I don't believe my in
my life I had a sane conversation with
my mother because of this it was
horrible I didn't realize
how difficult knowing that you're going
to lose your child could be but it got
really bad uh when I was born in October
1963 uh my brother died 11 days later in
the same hospital and so my mother
linked me coming into the world with his
death and my childhood was not pretty I
uh I had uh all kinds of I was a cerian
birth and I've learned that there could
be some issues with cerian birth I had
really severe allergies I had
OCD I was sick a lot and I drove my
mother nuts absolutely nuts and I had a
psychotherapist tell me you know did
something happen in your childhood to
make you so driven that you have to
prove yourself all the time I'm like no
I I told this part of the story and then
it occurred to me that whenever I was
bad my mother would scream at me and say
why did God take Frankie and not
you and I called my older sister when I
had this Revelation I go Debbie did you
ever hear Mommy say that to me and she
goes all the time I had suppressed that
like completely suppressed it but my
response was some version
of I'm worth it I I'll prove it to you
um you know what I mean so I had this
drive that was so uh unknown to me from
childhood so fast forward a little bit
when I was 11 my dad comes home from
work one day he had been having
backaches and we didn't have a lot of
money He's Got U he was in the car
business and he's raising all these kids
and he comes home and he he says i' I've
got some news really bad bad news and he
was crying and he said um uh I've got
cancer and in the first visit to the
doctor they said it's in your L um your
lungs your kidneys your bones and your
brain they gave him six weeks to live
first visit and I had an aunt who was
into natural cures and stuff and she got
radical she completely changed uh the
food in the house and long story short
he ended up living 2 and 1/2
years and in those 2 and A2 years he
basically set us up for life and you so
you have to think about it we're in uh
North Jersey right outside New York
City um it's the 70s he died in
1977 we really had no parents after that
cuz my mother was in no shape to raise
us and all of us are married uh over 250
years of marriage no divorces between
all the siblings isn't that crazy yeah
and I think there's like I said 44
nieces and nephew I have 44 nieces and
nephews when you en count the grand
nieces but my point is that when he was
dying I just became a sponge for
everything he believed in and what he
taught I went to church every Sunday and
prayed a lot but I'll never forget after
he died there was a um service and the
priest said it was a big service cuz we
we we were like a very known family with
all the kids and the priest said in life
you know I'm in the audience and he said
let me tell you a story and he said my
hope is that one of you here here's what
I'm about to say and I'm like for some
reason I got this Zing almost like a
spiritual Zing I said he's talking to me
and it was a massive crowd there was 13
or so it was right after he died I was
13h and um he goes in life you could
choose to be the the horse or the rider
of the horse but whatever you choose
life becomes the other thing he said you
can choose to become the horse life
becomes the rider and life will take you
wherever it wants you to go like like
that's pretty cool he said
or you could choose to become the rider
and life becomes the horse and you could
take it wherever you wanted to go and I
remember at 13 saying I'm getting on
that horsey and it was just an awesome
experience that the despite the fact
that we had no money despite the fact
that I had no parents uh I mean I had a
mom but it wasn't there was no
relationship
really um I just realized at that point
like I could go with my friends who were
doing bad things or I could go this way
and it was around that time that as luck
would have it I uh got my first Mentor
his name is James
O'Donald and um he's recently passed but
he heard that I was good at math now I'm
really young I was in like fifth grade
at the time so when my dad got sick I
was I think it was at the beginning of
my fifth grade when he died I was in
seventh grade it was at the end of my
seventh grade anyway long story short I
had never been exposed to money or
entrepreneurism or any of that and James
O'Donnell took me out to lunch one day
and he said I heard you're good at math
I said okay he said if you uh get an
engineering degree like I did it will
train your brain to think and it will uh
it will help you in business you could
be a doctor a lawyer a business person
you could work on Wall Street you could
do whatever you want but get an
engineering degree and this is really
funny as a young guy anytime somebody
asked me after that what are you going
to do with your life I would say I don't
know but I'm going to get an engineering
degree because I could become a doctor a
lawyer I could work on Wall Street I
could do whatever I want because it'll
drain my brain I literally repeated that
here's this messed up part about that
story I had one meeting with James
O'Donnell and the meeting was he told me
this and he said let me take you to my
company and I'll never forget I walk in
this building got his name on the door
was all these drafts people it seemed
like hundreds to my young eyes and
they're addressing him Mr O'Donnell and
I'm like wow I want to be a business guy
and it's funny how people miss those
opportunities they miss as the recipient
and they miss as The Giver one meeting I
had with him it lasted about two hours
so let's fast forward uh there was my
house was not uh organized I never got
letters in the mail but I'll never
forget I was 18 and um there was a
letter sitting on the stack had on the
stack of mail on the TV set and it said
my name on it I'm like what the hell was
that and it said from the state in of
New Jersey I'm getting emotional
thinking about
it and I open the letter up and I'm like
unbelievable if you want something bad
enough the universe conspires to bring
it to you and um it said Mr sapio you
got the one one of the 10 highest scores
uh in your math sat and we're going to
give you a free ride to ruers
engineering school and I'm like holy
this is unbelievable cuz I had no
hope my mother wanted me to work for the
gas station on the corner because she's
like we need money and this is like one
of those searing moments in your life
you can't I can't ever forget it I'm was
so excited I showed it to my mother and
she she looks at the letter and she goes
you're not going to college and rips the
letter up and I'm like wow the only way
for me to get what I want in my life I
have to break and I literally just broke
I break away when I went to college I
was there for 5 years it was a 5-year
program I never went home I was there I
built my life there so my Independence
skyrocketed and I have to tell you it
was brutally hard I went to a public
school I get there and I had never seen
so many Asian I or Indians in one place
I remember they did the first roll call
and they got to Raj Patel and seven guys
stood
up and you're from a very Italian
neighborhood so that was pretty much
what you knew right cultur knew I didn't
and what was weird about is they curved
all their tests so I never saw calculus
before I didn't know what it was and all
these different things that we learned
chemistry calculus physics they had
already been exposed to it and the tests
are curved and the first two years I ERS
is this the the third lowest grades you
get booted so one out of three people
got booted and so it was brutally hard
for me because I had never really
applied myself and now um I'm just not
going to quit I'm one of those guys if
I'm saying I'm going to do something I'm
going to do it so anyway I I go through
Ruckers and um what I learned is about
myself as an adult now that I got from
childhood is the immense chaos of my
childhood just think about all those
things and what probably
transpired forced me and caused me to
say I have to know answers I need to
seek patterns and solutions because I
don't ever want to have that chaos so my
entire adult life has been all about
creating simple systems to live a
fulfilling life and to have success and
a lot of those systems have come out in
terms of modules and formulas and ways
of doing things and things we've
trademarked things like the catalyzing
statement but all the 48 modules that
became business finishing school was all
the way to say listen if you want an
easier way to live your life Rick and
people that are learning this stuff
this's very easy formulas to to to live
by it for example my wife and I in our
our marriage we sat down when my wife
was pregnant first and I said honey I
don't know well I'm going to share a
simple one uh that's where I'm going I
said honey I don't know if I'm going to
live past 50 CU my dad died at 50 she's
like okay well you're
45 and I said if we have kids I want to
do for them what my dad did for me and
we created this thing called a family
placemat and on that family placement is
35 PODS of information it includes our
family values it includes our family
Rules it includes what we talk about a
family meetings it includes what my wife
and I talk about when we have meetings
it says on there that we're going to
have date every Monday night at 7:30 it
has our wedding vows on there it has our
family crest and what it means it has
Ben Franklin's 13 virtues it's been on
our dinner table since the day my son
was born and he has seen it and have all
four of our kids have memorized this
thing and it's basically if something
happens to me or Mom here's what we
stand for to me that's incredibly
simplifying and our kids are thriving so
the three operating values that we have
in our business and in our family is
Simplicity probability and leverage
these are lenses that you look through
which and this is the whole thing like
you know when you talk about you know
operating values
Simplicity now that I'm hearing more
your background because I always know
you're like the Simplicity guy in many
respects you crave Simplicity you demand
Simplicity you force Simplicity into
existence and it's not just in your
businesses but also in your personal
life for all the reasons maybe that you
just said now that motivated you um so
what does it mean if to have a lens like
that if you're if you're in a business
to look through it and say Simplicity
probability leverage just briefly
explain what each of those things mean
to you so Simplicity speaks for itself
we live in a chaotic complex world and I
like to dumb things down as much as
possible because we can't get things
done unless it's simple and so every
time an opportunity comes up in my
family or in my business I'm like is
this going to simplify my life or is
this going to complicate my life and
it's a daily debate and um you know an
example of that in our family is uh you
know we try to go out to dinner with
other other couples sometimes and a lot
and they're like well we got to get a
babysitter we got my wife and I have not
missed a date night Monday night at 7:30
date night now why do we do that because
it's simple babysitter knows kids know
Neighbors Know employees know the
restaurant knows cuz we only go to one
or two places and it it completely has
gelled our marriage and Monday nights
why Monday cuz restaurants are empty so
it's quiet and you do you think about
those kind of rhythms in all areas of
your life I've been working out with the
same trainer for 11 years 30 sets and 30
minutes 5:30 in the morning boom simple
and you apply those into business and it
kind of creates a lot of automation we
don't have to think about date night I
don't have to think about working out I
don't have to think about a lot of the
meetings that we have so that's
Simplicity probability is an interesting
one I believe that um and there's all
kinds of stats on this it's a great book
on The Power of Habit by Charles doig
where he says more than 95% of what you
do and what I do on a daily basis is
unconscious we don't add conscious
thought to it we just do it and so
probability forces you and me to add
Consciousness to our decisions and so
probability means if you do something in
business is this going to increase the
probability that you hit the stated
objective if you do something in your
personal life is this going to increase
the probability of you hitting the
stated objective and people don't think
like that so uh example I like to use is
you know your office manager quits you
need to hire somebody quickly do you
hire the best person you could possibly
find in the city or do you hire your uh
out of work alcoholic sister-in-law and
most people just bring something in they
don't think about it they got to fill a
spot and they destroy their company but
one cool thing and I brought this up to
my wife a thousand times I'm driving her
nuts I'm like honey what do we want our
kids to be when they're 18 and we've
laid it out we want 18-year-olds that
are like me and my wife were independent
entrepreneurial able to make money um
and so on our place met it says you will
never receive an inheritance from Mom or
Dad we want to teach you how to fish so
our kids are like motivated even though
the old is 12 so they're 12 10 8 and six
but anyway if we want to increase the
probability that our kids are those
independent 18-year- olds right what do
we do we certainly aren't going to drive
them around in club sports and take them
to different cities because they're good
athletes no we're going to teach them
the things that they're going to need as
adults so I met with this is an awesome
story I went to the best private school
in Dallas that I could find when Luke
was a baby my oldest and I sat down and
I'll never forget this meeting as long
long as I live I said uh doctor how many
kids have you graduated in your life he
was about 65 and he goes thousands why I
go let me ask you a question the best
kids that you have ever had can you
think of a few he goes yeah I said what
did their parents
do and he said no one ever asked me
that's a great question and he goes I
have the answer for you here's what you
do no TV in the house no cell phones
make sure they learn how to play the
piano they have to learn discipline so
put them in martial arts and wrestling
get a chess coach CU it'll train their
brain and um have dinner every night as
a family those were some there was more
but I'm just so I went home I was like
I'm like
honey and she's like you're crazy so
here I am looking at you 12 years later
my son is a concert pianist he's testing
for his black belt in karate he's
thriving in school he also was an
incredible rated chess player and what
we we realize from all that stuff is you
could read about this in deep work that
what we're actually teaching our kids to
do is
focus when you put devices in people's
hands and you drive them all over the
place mom has to get on a plane because
there's a soccer tournament in New York
the other one has a soccer tournament in
California the family split apart we
have family dinner every night I said
all that to say we make decisions
consciously to increase the probability
of that outcome that we want so all of
us have that so that's probability in
but from the business side is is that
just the question like you say Okay I
want to create wealth in my life because
that's the theme Here Right would you
look at any decision you're making say
okay does this increase or decrease the
probability that I can be create the
wealth I want to create is it that kind
of that simple so I love the way you
said it here's the bottom line
everything that we do as business people
We should strive to do things as simple
as possible that increase the
probability that we have the stated
outcome now the stated outcome for me
and for people watching here would be to
create wealth MH and use high
probability decision-making to do that
but often times people use low
probability so this is just an
interesting thing we hear it our whole
whole life Buy Low sell high but when
people buy homes they look at
neighborhoods after they've appreciated
they buy Apple after it's appreciated
they get excited about tulips in Holland
after they've appreciated the name of
the game is Buy Low and sell High
completely highly prob it's it's highly
probable but it's completely against
human
nature after the market crashed in 2008
it was devastatingly low what were
individual investors doing they were
running what was Warren Buffett doing he
was running except he was running in a
different direction he was buying as
much as he could at the bottom he knows
that good markets follow bad markets and
he's just trained himself to you know
when there's blood in the streets that
that's when you buy so that's a highly
probable decision when you buy a company
at a low whether it's a stock or I don't
care what you do for a living or you buy
into a neighborhood at a low you know
that highs follow lows right but it's so
so hard to do you know I think about the
banking industry and I'll never forget
this story I don't want to say his last
name but I had a banker in in in Dallas
Texas and they were loaning money with
10% down to buy buildings so 10% down
you buy a $50 million building you put
$5 million down and they loan you n uh
45 million fine doing those loans all
day long after the market crashes he
says to me I wouldn't do a loan on that
same building for half the price because
a client came in to do that so they just
loan money at 50 million but they
wouldn't loan money at a valuation of 25
million with 50 % down like why wouldn't
you do that he says cuz we're a banker
we follow the herd we're Bankers we
follow the herd it's just and I think
Bankers kind of train us to think to
take risk at highs you follow my logic
here if I was a banker and I'm not I
would wait for low lows and do loans
anybody any entrepreneur aggressive
enough to put a lot of money down on a
commercial building at the market low
I'm in I want somebody like that I want
somebody who's smart enough and uh makes
decisions in a highly probable way so
and you look at this stuff I think you
know just in your own business
activities I mean you have varying funds
you know the public funds private funds
uh private Equity Funds so you make
investments you look for these types of
things this is kind of you're looking
all day long you're trying to make these
decisions and I know about you too
because you if if you say hey this is
got a high probability of success but
the deal is complicated you don't want
it so like do you these things ever
wrestle with each other yeah yeah
unfortunately today and you see we all
see it is it used to be when I was a
turnaround guy in my 20s you take over a
company you make quick decisions you
could turn a business around quickly
today unfortunately something's crept
into society and into business that's
horrible and I call it electronic sludge
do you remember 20 years ago you meet
somebody you want to raise money you
shake their hands they sit give you a
check the next day now everybody's
online they're sending emails and text
messages and they're checking you out
and they're talking to their attorney
and they're waiting for everything seems
to have slowed down into electronic
sludge so now more than ever you've got
to find deals and opportunities that are
simple because the complexity is growing
exponentially and this electronic sludge
is not going away and everybody sees it
but nobody identifies it as such and so
I think it's more important now than
ever and it's also more important um the
guy who wrote the book deep work one of
the things that he's concluded is since
money is kind of a
commodity uh the thing that separates
the halves and the have not have nots
are in business is this ability to focus
50 years ago if you had a job you're
working for four hours at a time on your
job you're working now people are
working in 7 second slugs they start
working and then bing bing bing bing
bing
so the people that have the ability the
confidence and the diligence to be
hyperfocused in their job for hours at a
time those are the people that are going
to make it because they actually you
can't make progress you know the people
that are this way Jeff Bezos Bill Gates
Warren Buffett Steve Jobs Steve Jobs was
a low Tech parent they did a great
interview in which they went to his home
to see how how many devices he had in
his house just before he died because he
had three kids and Steve said we don't
have devices in our house um the iPhone
and the iPad wasn't meant for kids
that's the quote in the New York Times
so why is it these Titans of Industry
have figured out deep work but the
average population is is mired in
electronic sludge and of course you have
to have Netflix going you got to have
your Facebook and you got to have easy
access so this this is the Divide right
now those who can focus and who have
trained their kids to focus and whove
trained their employees to focus and
everybody else and I think it's probably
about 1% are in this category so it
leads me to something I want to share
with you after 2008 when the market
crashed I was scared because I'm in the
fund business right all of our assets
were weighed down and through a series
of very Forest things I had the
opportunity to meet Boon Pickins t- boom
pickets and t- boom pickets was this
massive Larger than Life character he's
a billionaire unbelievably wellknown
when I went to his house he had pictures
all over his house of like every famous
person you could possibly meet including
every president and at one of our
meetings I'll never forget it was 2007
he gets this call and he's kind of
yelling at the guy and it was a long
call and uh he kept calling him W ww and
he hangs up the phone and I'm like who
are you talking to he goes that was
President Bush he needed some advice
he's yelling at the
guy so after meeting him and he he
introduced me to a lot of very famous
billionaires I spent a lot of time with
these people you said I mean you set an
agenda to go interview a certain amount
of billionaires yeah right what caus you
to want to do that because I was scared
I wanted to interview people that have
been through a lot of ups and downs who
were self-made and I met uh people like
Richard Branson and um I was mentored by
Warren Buffett in my in my 20s that he
wasn't part of this but here's what I
learned about very very successful
people that have been successful in
business and I'll explain it by way of a
story this is a famous story of the guy
the inventor named Dean Cayman and Dean
Cayman is probably the most prolific
inventor that ever lived he invented the
segue he invented that cool Coca-Cola
machine that uh where you just picked
the the flavor but he's had hundreds and
hundreds of successful uh products and I
heard this from somebody uh who was
there that he was in a meeting 10 years
ago and uh at the time he was probably
55 I don't know how old he was and
they're in a board meeting and he's
talking about you know the task at hand
and people before the meeting started we
talking about Madonna and he's listening
and apparently Madonna was in you know
front page news and he goes I may be the
only stupid one here but who the hell is
Madonna I think that's awesome if you
are so focused on your work that you
have no idea about pop culture I think
that's awesome and people that move the
needle and culture and Society um from a
business perspective they're just
focused and here's what I
learned every single person that I
interviewed had a very simple life and I
boiled it down to my five finger rule
for success in business if you know what
your five priorities are in life M you
move the ball down the field so far so
let me give you an example I have a
friend I don't want to say his name but
he's famous M and he always says God
first family second career third health
and fitness fourth and uh I'm like
awesome you say that all the time so I I
was really excited to meet his wife and
kids so I flew out to California one
weekend I I was single at the time and I
land and he picks me up uh in a
limousine there was weird people in the
car with him uh we drive to a restaurant
and he's trying to impress me he got a
private room and there was a lot of
alcohol and weird people then he at the
end we go to a strip club and he knew a
lot of people there we go home it's late
at night his wife and kids are asleep we
wake up early in the morning we go play
golf I I hope that you love golf I don't
care I hate golf I'm not going to do
anything for four
hours chasing a ball around uh I
personally hate golf I I'm sure the
industry is great and I apologize to you
golfers out there but we play golf all
day and then he goes to another
restaurant with another weird group of
people and then Sunday morning comes and
I had to go I never met his wife I never
met his kids so just listen to this God
first family second health and fitness
fourth whatever his priority was what I
learned about these wealthy people and
these successful people these people
that had massive impact is they only do
their
priorities so what I've determined and
I've been working on this for 10 years
that my number one priority is being a
husband but wait a minute back up for
because it sounds like what his
priorities were and what his life were
we're not aligned 100% so what's the
point what's the moral of that story so
here's the moral okay what I realized
from him and all these billionaires is
my number one priority is being a great
husband being a great father comes after
that number two health and fitness
because if I'm not alive like my dad
didn't treat his body well he died
number three is my career and purpose
work number four is my key relationships
like my relationships with business Etc
and number five is Learning and
Development now here's the thing if you
follow these people around that are
crystal clear on their purpose they get
up in the morning at 5:00 a.m. and you
follow them around with a video camera
all day long what you will find is that
almost 100% of their waking hours
they're dealing with their priority a
priority what you find with that
gentleman you just asked about and the
vast majority of the planet is they say
this is my priority but they spend 90%
of their time doing something else if
you want success in business and you
want to create immense wealth for
yourself figure out what your five
priorities are and only do that that's
why Dean Cayman story is so compelling
to me he was crystal clear on what he
had to do when he was when he was awake
I read a lot about Roman history and you
know uh I don't know if people don't
even know this but the college
in Rome there was 440 of those
throughout the Roman uh 440 of those
massive coliseums why because people
just needed to be led into
unconsciousness and I think that's what
media does that's what uh technology
does so it pulls people away from their
five and the interesting thing about the
five which I have taught my kids is
where does God fit into all this like
who who made you uh somebody made you
when I put God right in the middle God's
in the Palm but I said to my son when he
was 11 he was questioning spirituality I
said Luke what's the most incredible
thing that was ever created and he goes
a computer and I said okay uh what about
the human brain he goes oh the human
brain I said who created that he goes a
really smart
person so some I don't care where
anybody is religiously or spiritually
but the most complex organism that's
ever been that's ever been
identified something powerful had to
create that so I I put that guy right
there so you talked about um Simplicity
and probability you didn't mention
leverage what is leverage and how do you
apply it so I'm going to talk about
leverage by way of a story but leverage
to me is when you do anything it should
be leveraging your existing
infrastructure or your existing
relationships and in business and wealth
creation I often see people making
Investments that don't take advantage of
what's already in place so leverage
comes in many forms you could leverage
technology that you already have so
often times uh in business I see
companies they're going down a path they
have a strategy and I want to talk about
business strategy in a moment which is
big for wealth creation they have a
strategy but they're doing things over
here and I see this a lot uh unrelated
but you know I see a lot of doctors you
know they they start making money and
they decide to buy the building that
they're in and sometimes that works out
but I've seen a lot of times where it
hasn't worked out and it's added so much
complexity if I'm a doctor what if I
leverage my knowledge of medicine to
create a product for the marketplace so
Leverage is leveraging existing
infrastructure existing technology
existing relationships so when I talk
about leverage or you know thinking
about a new opportunity I first say is
it simple to implement this
opportunity is it um probable is it
increasing the probability that we hit
the stated objective and is it
leveraging something that's already in
place I asked those questions Southwest
Airlines supposedly this is a fact I
have not done the math myself but when
Southwest Airlines went public the first
30 years that was public from like 74 to
2004 it was the best performing stock of
all stocks in the United States an
airline an industry that Warren Buffett
used to say is the worst industry in the
world an airline startup was better
perform than Microsoft and Philip Morris
you think about that why because herb
Keller understood Simplicity probability
leverage and he employed that in his
business strategy so here's here's what
they did they took a a long time before
they started and they said how are we
going to make decisions in this firm and
they said we're going to pick a strategy
which is if you remember at the
beginning it was one plane the 737 we're
only going to do direct flights there's
no seed assignments there's no change
fees and on and on and on they had a big
focus on their people and their culture
but once they launched it was permanent
for three decades they didn't change it
wasn't until they got massive that they
started changing so an important part
about wealth creation in my view is
having permanence about your belief
systems I'm never going to change
Simplicity probability and leverage
Southwest Airlines said it's permanent
but what happens in most companies they
bring on a new executive we're going to
change this change this change that no
you've got to take time at the beginning
they took three or four years at the
beginning went through this immense
thought process and then they launched
and here's the cool thing about herb
cair he would say some version of what
I'm about to say he said the the best
businesses in the world employ this word
monotony and you're like monotony how is
monotony monotony is employed by Warren
Buffett he's got a very monotonous life
when a company knows exactly what it has
to do it's monotonous everybody knows
their role everybody knows what they're
trying to do we're just trying to get
better and better better at these short
Hall flight
and then once that monotony grows then
it starts expanding slowly but in a very
simple probable and leverageable way
when you think about a company if a
company isn't clear about its purpose
and its values and its catalyzing
statement and its
strategy how does it know if a new
opportunity is a great thing or a
massive distraction so until you've done
that work to come up with the reason the
company
exists and how it's going to make its
decisions and how it's monotonously is
executing on you know it's it its
objectives if you don't know what those
things are how the hell can you tell the
difference between a massive distraction
and an opportunity you can't so I want
to use the story about Jeff Bezos which
I think is really cool um there was a a
famous cover of one of the big magazines
magazine his pockets were inside out
yeah his pockets are inside out it said
some version of you know Amazon's going
bankrupt because Bezos won't change his
strategy his strategy was permanent now
I don't know if he articulated it this
way but I believe that a business
strategy which you know what who the
hell knows what a business strategy is
but if you're in business you better
have a strategy and I think as Jeff
Bezos did it's really simple what
business are you in when we make
investments in companies we look at a
thousand we make two Investments we
interview employees we say what business
are you in you get 20 different answers
Jeff Bezos Crystal Clear sell books two
wordss when he started Amazon it was to
sell books so it's what business are you
in so what who and how that's all the if
you have a crystal clear answer to those
three questions in business you're going
to create immense wealth for yourself so
answering the question what business are
you in sell books number two who who
someone with an internet connection
everybody thought you're insane only 4%
of people have an internet connection in
1994 he's like we're just going to focus
on those people what do you think about
it we forget you'll never compete with
borders you'll never compete with Barnes
and Noble they're going to flush you
down the toilet so uh what business sell
books to who people with an internet
connection how we're going to ship them
from warehouses cuz this books are small
easy to store we're going to ship them
with fourth rate mail so it answer the
question of the business model how you
deliver the product and it also answers
how do you Market we're going to Market
online so that was their strategy for 10
years and they burn through billions of
dollars but what happened is first of
all everybody said you're crazy because
you're never going to be able to compete
with Barnes & Noble and everything else
he goes if you focus on a strategy long
enough what happens you add Simplicity
probability and leverage why because you
start building momentum if the strategy
is well thought out and then people
start spreading and saying hey I got my
book on Amazon and then they start
shipping books to their friends because
it's easy and it just spreads and only
when they had Mass did he do what
started adding other products it's a
massive lesson in creating wealth
through a business and here's the cool
thing that everybody forgets in my
opinion
permanence when my wife and I created
that placement we said here it is it's
permanent when herb Kare created
Southwest aines
as long as I'm alive it's permanent when
Jeff Bezos laid out the strategy it was
permanent and you only add to it using
leverage things that are taking
advantage of existing infrastructure or
existing relationships or existing
technology Amazon is a brilliant example
of this but here's the thing anybody can
do this anybody can employ a simple
business strategy to create wealth
anybody can make decisions from a
Simplicity probability and leverage
standpoint um so explain what you mean
by catalyzing statement what does that
mean so I think this whole purpose
statement mission
statement values all these all
convoluted things and so we went out and
we looked at the marketplace and what we
realized is that the the world is too
complex we came up with this term about
15 years ago called a catalyzing
statement and a catalyzing statement is
a statement that catalyzes your your
important stakeholders to help you
stakeholders are employees and vendors
and the marketplace in general could be
um your your community around you so a
catalyzing statement massively catalyzes
action and anybody can create a
catalyzing statement and so uh the story
I love to tell is I I loved uh lyell's
Pizza it was lovey where I grew up it
the best pizza in town and all the owner
wanted to do was I just want to go back
to Italy I make it the best of pizza and
this guy worked his ass off and died
making pizza he was so pissed off when
this crappy pizza came along Domino's
Pizza he doesn't know a damn thing about
pizza and Tom uh Monahan who created
dominoes sold the business for more than
a billion dollars why because of a
catalyzing statement you could sell
crappy food and turn into a billion
dollars and ironically he's got a bigger
estate in Italy than lella could ever
possibly have but here's the thing 30
minutes or less or it's free that
catalyzed so much action why it
catalyzed people who want to drive fast
to make tips who became their managers
talk about leverage it catalyzed um a
meme in society 30 minutes or less or
it's free you think about massive things
that have happened in societ of
impossible things jonath Kennedy knew
there was no way we're going to get to
the moon and back there not that's not
even possible and the Russians were
kicking our ass yeah so when he
inherited the Space Program all it was
was about beating the Soviets he created
a catalyzing statement when he said
we're going to send the man to the moon
and return him safely to Earth by the
end of the decade what did that do it
catalyzed Massive Action the rumor was
they got 100,000 resumés for people that
wanted to help and it made decision-
making easier so when somebody came to
them with a new technology is that going
to get us to the moon and back in seven
years no next next next and you think
about there was a crappy car maker
called Volvo and they had expensive cars
that weren't really good until an
engineer put a stake in the
ground we build the safest cars in the
world and that company turned around
overnight and Engineers that wanted to
build safe cars came for it that they
were a stakeholder pregnant mom said I'm
not buying a Cadillac I'm buying a Volvo
they build the safest cars in the world
it catalyzed all this action and they
went from I think like 10th or 13th in
the world to Fourth and then what
happened
some CEO comes along and says nah we
don't we're not about safety anymore
we're about performance this should
bounce that guy but you think about all
these ideas you know Fred Smith he got a
C on his paper Federal Express what did
he say what may put fa you know you're
going to compete with the US government
you're going to raise a $100 million in
1975 and you're going to buy 90 planes
that ship packages all you really going
to do that only if you have a catalyzing
statement what was it when you
absolutely posit positively has to be
there overnight I remember it well you
still remember from 30 years ago yeah so
that meeme so here's the cool thing
about catalyzing
statements anyone can create one and
what does it do it adds Simplicity
probability and leverage to your life
and there's thousands of them we uh
created a charity because my purpose in
life is to inspire entrepreneurship and
I I surmised that there's probably about
a billion homes in the world and our
catalyzed statement became an
entrepreneur in every home uh a billion
entrepreneurs wouldn't the world be
pretty cool with a billion entrepreneurs
and and Define what an entrepreneur is
to you an entrepreneur is very simply
anybody who takes responsibility for
outcomes you could be a stay-at-home mom
whose outcome who's you know that you're
pushing probability toward is I want to
create independent kids and that becomes
your Mantra that's the catalyzing
statement for the stay-at-home mom who
you know in the entrepreneurial context
that you have so any anybody that takes
responsibility for outcomes is an
entrepreneur and you know the old French
definition was somebody who takes
resources from one level and brings them
to another if you're a human being that
decides to take responsibility no matter
where you are in your life and you use
the resources that you have and you own
those resources who cares about your
childhood or anything else you're being
entrepreneurial when you decide to take
responsibility so that's our definition
so what's interesting I think in
summarizing some of this so Simplicity
probability and leverage mhm catalyzing
statement and you you've said this
multiple times and tell me if you truly
truly believe it anybody can do this
anybody can do this it's frustrating
when I meet run into friends and you
know they're 11 years in I'm like still
thinking about my catalyzing statement
and a catalyzing statement is all it is
is a get to of a purpose statement uh
Bill Gates is a fantastic example of
this he wanted to build the most
recognizable software company in the
world in his 20s and it was going and
you know he's a good businessman but he
said these famous words and he changed
everything everything the computer on
every desktop yeah I Envision a world
with a computer on every desktop and he
said it over and over and over and
almost going back to monotonous the
really best CEOs on Earth are monotonous
they repeat themselves over and over and
over but everybody else thinks success
is all about changing and adapting to no
it's about finding your purpose turning
your purpose into catalyzing statement
like Bill Gates he wants to have the
most recognizable software company the
world how do I make it a get to a
computer a desktop we're going to beat
the Soviets in the Space Race how do I
make it a get to we're going to send a
man to the moon and return him safe with
their Earth before the end of the decade
yes and so the cool thing is none of the
things that we've talked about here that
have created immense wealth for people
none of them are difficult they're all
relatively simp simple but just like
dieting It's relatively simple eat less
and exercise more but for some reason
people choose not to execute on that so
I'm hoping that you execute on these
simple things so this has been
absolutely
mesmerizing and uh but I know that you
have built through Simplicity
probability and leverage a series of
principles that you apply to your
business activities that you've taught
to thousands tens of thousands out there
in the world that people can adopt now I
want to have a little bit of a lightning
round with you CU I happen to know what
you teach in business the principles you
and I have known each other for years
we're an accountability group together
every week you'd be coming to the phone
with these a different business
principle and I'd be like writing
Furious like oh my God this stuff is
gold so what you've taught me in the way
of these principles has had a massive
impact on my My Success my wealth
development but also on my experience in
life the first one you talk about is
values-based
decisionmaking and then you translate
that into what you call the doorman
principle explain that please values
based decision making presupposes that
you have a set of values that guide your
decisions in business no one's conscious
of this but just imagine two morons they
don't have a college degree they decide
they're going to start a company
together uh they're shunned by Society
because they're both weird their names
are Steve and Steve and they built a
trillion dollar company named Apple did
anyone ever think like how is that
possible everybody goes to business
school how did two guys decide to how
did they do this and there's a little
known story inside Apple that uh they
weren't doing well they were losing
money this guy named marula comes along
it's 1977 and he says
um I will invest
$250,000 in you think about it$ 250,000
I want 40% of the company but every
decision from this point forward has to
be made according to this list of values
it's called the marula document nobody
even knows about it and when you look at
that marula document you're like holy
everything Apple does stems back to
a document in
1977 so this isn't hard folks if you
have a list of values that your company
operates from starting with Simplicity
probability and leverage and you could
go look up the Apple document if you you
want magic has to happen after that
because what happens is you're making
decisions that are very consistent with
a set of values I know about you and I
know about me and I know about all you
guys watching out there that every
single problem that I have ever had and
that you have ever had started when I
let someone or something into my life
that didn't align with my values and I
have to say you said that on the phone
to me 10 years ago maybe yeah and uh and
and I rejected the comment when when you
said I said no that's not true there's
there's other reasons why I had major
problems in my life and then I started
to go back and look at the lawsuits or
the challenge whatever the things were
and I EV you were every single major
challenge I had was because I let
someone in my life that did not share my
values it was 100% accurate when I
applied it and we know scientifically
now that your brain rationalizes
everything so let's say you have a clear
set of values and you meet somebody oh
I'm going to make a lot of money your
brain your gut only says yes no mhm your
gut is gut your gut is God uttering
truth and every time you don't listen to
gut every single time you me everybody
every time it's like why did I listen
them my gut so what what I do with
values based decision making is I have a
crystal clear set of values that I make
decisions from in my business and in my
personal life and they're imprinted in
my gut and to this day when I get into
an opportunity my guts screaming no and
I'm like but but but but but so this is
something that you have to be vigilant
about and what did we learn together
that the only way to be vigilant about
stuff like this is you can't do it in a
vacuum you have to have accountability
so I met a group of billionaires uh
years ago now 20 years ago and they
started meeting at the age of 30 when
they were just getting along in life and
they met every single week in the
basement of a church for 40 years
Wednesday morning 6:30 in Minneapolis St
Paul and this group of eight men created
four billionaires it's crazy why because
of the accountability so the
accountability is when we you know when
we meet every week is hold me
accountable to this set of values
because it's hard to do on your own so
values based decision making and where
was it born so I'm 16 remember I've got
six older siblings and I'm watching the
chaos of their lives I'm watching who
they live with and who they marry and uh
what they chose to do for a living and
their commute times and stupid things
like drugs and alcohol I'm saying it's
got to be a better way and that's where
Simplicity was born and that's where
values based decision-making was born it
was born when I was 16 when I wrote my
first uh set of values so as I said a
lot of how I've become in life was born
out of my childhood so here's the thing
about values based decision-making when
you come up with a list of values for
your business and for your personal life
you got to have the accountability and
so there's a built-in system that we've
created and it's in our book who's in
your room but we call it the doorman and
I imagine that um there's a doorman
sitting at the room of my life and that
doorman will only let people in that
align with my values so an example of
that is last week I was asked to be on
the board of a company and I said by Bob
I am so happy that you asked me but my
door man won't let me do this it's like
who's your doorman I go he's the guy
that holds my values so I blame it on
somebody
else and if I accept this boor position
with you I'm honored that you asked me
but if I accept it I'm not going to do a
good job for you so it's going to hurt
you and it's going to hurt me but you
blame it on a third party so the doorman
principal is unbelievable there was a
woman uh I'll call her Jenny 10 years
ago
now she was crying I I I met her at an
event
actually and she's like literally
balling her eyes at she just got off the
phone with her husband her 16-year-old
daughter she had four daughters
16-year-old was the oldest she was
dating a drug addict for two years they
were robbing from the house they having
sex in the house she would not see her
own daughter for sometimes a week at a
time absolutely positively destroying
this family she's like what should I do
I'm like well you're asking me I'm not a
psychotherapist and I said let me just
teach you values-based decision-making
and the doorman principle next time time
you're with your daughter sit down with
her ask her what her values are ask her
what the values are of the perfect man
for her and then I T to the doorman
principal so I don't know how long later
45 days later I get this freak call from
her she calls me if she's crying on the
phone and I'm like oh my God is she in
jail is she dead what happened she goes
you're not going to believe what
happened I taught her the values based
decision- making and the dman principal
and she started listing uh words for her
future boyfriend her husband honesty
Integrity hardworking God-fearing like
words I had never heard come out of her
mouth and I kind of forgot about it we
went on our way about 3 weeks later I'm
having breakfast with my
husband and she walks into the kitchen
and no one says a word and we were
scared to even say anything she goes Mom
Dad I broke up with
Trevor and they were like in shock and
the mom goes why'd you break up with
them and she said he didn't align with
my values and you think about all that
would have been destroyed in their
future one simple conversation values
based decision-making built a trillion
dollar company and saved the family and
all the
destruction and it only works if you sit
down and write out your values and what
they mean to you and if you can't do
that I won't do that I can't help you so
one of the things that you said relative
to this that
stuck uh one of our calls you said
absence absent of clear values one
cannot distinguish between opportunity
and distraction how do you know if you
haven't written out your purpose
statements which you could do in five
minutes a a purpose isn't out there it's
in here you peel it away to get to it
and people are looking out there they're
it's the most insane thing if you want
to know what your purpose is it's no
different than an acorn an acorn has
every every single thing it needs to
become a giant oak tree you have
everything you need inside of you but
you've got to be willing to peel the
onion and go inside and that's where
your purpose lies and that's where your
values lie I believe in my heart of
hearts that your values and your
purpose are are inside your DNA but if
you're not willing to do the work to
peel back and write them out then I
can't help you so let me just say say
the quote that we say often at at our
company unless you're crystal clear on
your purpose and your values and your
catalyzing statement and your main
objectives you have absolutely no
ability to distinguish between something
that's going to help your life and
something that's going to destroy your
life how do you know if you didn't do
the work so beautiful next you teach
management by objectives what's that so
management by objectives is uh I love
the quote from uh I heard him say it too
he's a crotchety old guy now sorry Jack
Welch but Jack Welch used to say uh tell
me what your quarterly objectives are as
a human being and as a company what are
the five things you want to get done
just tell me what they are next quarter
what do you want to get done and tell me
what do you want to do as your five
objectives 20 years from now if you know
what you got to do this quarter and you
know what you you want to do 20 years
from now the middle takes care of itself
I love that quote because everybody's in
this murky world what do you need to do
now that aligns with what you're doing
in 20 years and Magic happens that all
presupposes though my opinion that
you've got a purpose for the company and
for yourself and you've got values for
the company and yourself the next step
is management by objectives what are the
quarterly objectives what are the
long-term objectives and each quarter
you sit down with your team and you come
up with five objectives for the company
here's the interesting thing people have
a lot of problems with their
employees and I think that all of those
problems stem from no Clarity on purpose
no Clarity on values and no Clarity on
objectives I sit down with my Executives
and I say here's where we're gone here's
our company objectives what are your
five objectives and so on a quarterly
basis they get bonused on their five
objectives here's the cool thing people
hate employee reviews it's the easiest
employee review in the world how'd you
doing your five objectives did you do
them and people say what about values
well the objectives are going to align
with the values right so it's such an
easy straightforward thing and it boils
down to what we call the five ways to
pay people so when small company
entrepreneurs come to me they want to
get big I I tell them look um if you
want this to be simple highly probable
and leverageable to your existing
life then just do these simple things
you don't have to but here's one of
those simple things that we encourage
people to do pay employees five ways you
want want employees that are going to
stick around for the you know the Long
Haul so five ways give people a living
wage so a base salary I like base
salaries um I like benefits we use uh
peos a lot the professional employment
agencies where they do payroll and
benefits so you get like IBM benefits so
people have a base salary so when
they're going home and they're having
dinner with their spouse they're not
looking for another job or they're
saying I really love where I work
because they pay me five ways base
salary benefits the Third Way is a bonus
on them achieving their five quarterly
objectives that align with the company's
objectives the next thing is a
companywide bonus everybody gets the
same thing so everybody if we hit these
five objectives as a company everybody's
going to get 500 bucks at the end of the
quarter and I'm taking you to dinner at
the nicest restaurant in town so
everybody's pulling each other to to
achieve the same thing and then lastly
something long-term something that 10
years from now you're going to get or
employees stock options but my friend
Brett I love this uh on every employees
10 year anniversary he uh bought them a
cruise around the world and I'll never
forget he hired this new employee Sher
was her name and I went to his office I
go hey Sher nice to meet you and she
goes nine more
years I'm like nine more years oh she
goes I get my cruise in nine more years
this guy bought 10 years of employee
loyalty on a 5 $500 Cruise think about
that but he also paid him five ways and
so we complicate this so I often say
CEOs don't have a motivation problem
they have a compensation problem because
you've all seen the study uh 5 million
people were studied by
Gallup and what they found is they
interviewed employees of companies and
they found that 70% of 5 million people
either hated working for their company
working against it or looking for
another job some version of I don't want
to work here
70% they went back and reped a small
number of them like 5,000 and they said
this is too bizarre what would make you
go from the 70% that hate your job to
the 30% that love it we want to know
what the company stands for we want to
know what the values are we want to know
our
objectives this is simple why
aren't we doing
it next you uh this is one that really
made a big difference in my life rhythms
and rituals to amplify time and success
so when you think about great companies
they have baked into their culture
rhythms and rituals and often times uh
people do things once we're going to do
a new member drive or a new client drive
or a new uh Drive of some kind well if
it's the third Wednesday of the month
why don't you just do it forever the
third Wednesday of the month so now
everybody knows and you bake these
rhythms into your culture was everybody
has anybody ever consciously thought
about how tens of thousands of
McDonald's restaurants get open by 16y
olds in the morning and closed by 16y
olds at
night it's because of the rhythms and
habits baked in and I like to answer
this by way of an example I took over a
nonprofit board about 20 years ago it
was failing miserably and it was the
last in the world out of 180 offices
that did this thing it's not worth
getting into what it was so I get to the
board meeting and I just put a a a
calendar like six foot wide for the
whole year on the board and it was blank
and you could fill it in and I said um
how often do we have meetings for the
board they go monthly when do we have
them at the end of each meeting they
would say when do you want to meet the
next one I said well it's Wednesday
morning it's 8:00 let's have it uh the
first Wednesday of every month at 8:00
put it on the calendar when do we want
the um announcement for that meeting to
go out how about a week before put that
on the calendar when are we doing um our
fundraising well we generally do four
events a year why don't we announce that
they're two week weeks after the
beginning of every quarter four times
put that on the calendar when are we
doing our educational events well we
generally do them you know once a month
how about the second Tuesday every month
at 7 o' long story short we filled the
calendar in I said to the admin publish
this calendar and blow it out to all the
membership this organization in one year
went from
180th to number four why because the
Rhythm and the calendar ran the company
and great companies do that way so you
don't have to reinvent things every day
monotony it actually became monotonous
cuz the admin team would say I'm just
following the calendar and so any
company could do this and uh so that's
why we save for this module rhythms and
rituals that amplify time and success
and if you recall we talked about the
billionaires these guys that were in
their 30s that became billionaires why
every Wednesday 6:30 they knew what
chair they we're going to be in my wife
and I know every Monday at 7:30 where
we're going to be we're going to be on a
date night we're not going to be talking
about business why because on Wednesday
mornings at 8 we have a business meeting
that's when we do all that so rhythms
and rituals to amplify time and success
it works in your personal life it works
in your business life so let's maybe
kind of tie this all together uh with
the business frame so because what you
do you get it down to basically a sheet
I think right saying okay we're going to
if you put together this business frame
and you you say this over and over again
it's it you just do this work just the
discipline to get this one frame built
out and the probability of a successful
business goes way way up it's a simple
thing the frame is simple the
probability is high highly leverageable
because once you invest that time you're
going to have it and you keep running it
gets monotonous and that's when people
get bored and maybe start to stray off
the reservation right so just give us
the business frame if you don't mind so
what I'm about to tell you is a very
straightforward way that will increase
the probability that your business
creates wealth for you and your family
and for shareholders or whatever you
have and I often say you don't have to
do
this you could follow any method you
want but if you want Simplicity
probability and leverage here's a good
option for
you um we we once joked the opposite of
Simplicity probability and Leverage is
chaos death and frustration
um so any business any business should
have a purpose statement that's the
first step of the frame and it should be
four or five words we exist to solve
world hunger um a computer on every
desktop or whatever it's just simple so
if you do want to have Simplicity
probability and leverage you could
follow this simple frame and the first
step of the frame is your purpose
statement it's four or five words we
sell computers could be your purpose
statement if that's what you want your
purpose to be it could be a little bit
more enlightening like we we cure babies
of debilitating illnesses that's a
purpose but then you get to the
catalyzing statement and the catalyzing
statement is what turns the purpose into
something that catalyzes action in your
stakeholders and some really good
catalyzing statements o over the years
are um and we've talked about this too
you know America uh land of the free
home on the bridge
I think a statement like that is what's
causing people to want to come here for
250 years uh when it absolutely
positively has to be there overnight I
Envision a world with a computer on
every desktop we build the safest cars
in the world we can go on and on but a
catalyzing statement catalyze your
stakeholders again every single business
on planet Earth could do this and I've
coached a lot over the years I am not a
coach but people ask me purpose
statement catalyzing statement the next
thing is what are your values what are
the five or six values that you're going
to make all decisions from in your
business that's how two guys without a
college degree named Steve and Steve
created a trillion doll company trillion
doll company values based decision-
making write them out the next thing is
real business strategy your real
business strategy is what business are
you're in really short we sell books for
Amazon at the beginning right Southwest
Airlines we F fly direct short Hall
flights that's what we do then the next
question is who do you do it for not
what your avatar is it's just who people
with an internet connection people that
take buses in Southwest case they wanted
to convert people from buses to planes
and then lastly how do you do it and the
how was very short we're not talking
about a lot of thought short how do you
Market it and how do you deliver your
product or service and to use Amazon as
an example um their how is they ship
books by fourth rate mail because it was
was cheaper and they mark it online so
it answers both questions what who how
the next thing is 20-year objectives
your long-term objectives I don't care
people say this all the time I I want to
sell my business in 10 years well great
you're going to sell a business to
somebody they want to know where it's
going too it makes your line of sight
better if you know where you're going to
be in 20 years it helps make decisions
for what you need to do now so the next
part of it is long-term objectives what
are the five things you want this
company to have 20 years from now and
then the last part and you're done is
short-term objectives every quarter what
are the objectives for the business what
are the objectives for the employee now
once you have that laid out and I've
taken so many companies through it takes
a few hours that's it they fumble around
for 15 years and then a few hours to get
it right just like marula did with apple
here's the cool thing you then have to
wrap this around with I call it TDE
trust only hire people that trust that
frame that believe in that frame
discipline and execution you got to have
the discipline to follow it and then you
have to execute and here's the easy part
but no one does
it the very small number of Business
Leaders that do this have unbelievable
success they know what their frame is
and they may have their version of it
and might not be exactly like that and
then all they do is beat the drum and
never stop they do the same thing over
and over and over again that's why
really successful people sometimes are
boring uh I used to fancy myself a
singer and I sang open mic night uh at
Carolines in New York it was uh at the
height of Seinfeld Fame and I got behind
the mic I sang and uh Jerry Seinfeld
walks in and he's not that famous
anymore but at the time he was the most
famous TV star at least and he and he's
trips and he uh you know hey let me say
a few words and he gets up and he does
this 30 minute routine you know he burps
teases somebody in the audience trips
drops the mic a couple of times was
funny as hell two years later I'm in
Vegas and it says Jerry Seinfeld in big
light I'm like oh wow Jerry Seinfeld I'm
going to go see him so I got a ticket he
did the exact same routine exactly
famous people get really good and really
deep in what they do well and they do it
over and over and over again it's kind
of monotonous but if you want to have a
men's success figure out your purpose
your catalyzing statement your values
your strategy your long-term objectives
your short-term objectives put trust
discipline and execution and then repeat
yourself often that's success last thing
I want us to talk about
quickly you have recently told me you
adopted what you refer to as cathed
cedral thinking yeah you've adopted it
for your company you've adopted it for
yourself personally what is Cathedral
thinking so Cathedral thinking cuts
through the heart of everything we're
talking about when you're building a
cathedral you know that you're not
building it for yourself or your family
you're building it for people 500 years
from now and when you have very
long-term thinking we recently put
everything that we do around the
100-year
club when you do things for the Long
Haul what it does is it informs every
you everything you do now if you do it
right if you have a crystal clear
picture a legacy of what you want your
business or your life to look like a
hundred years from now what it does is
it changes how you do things today so if
I want to live to be 120 years old it's
going to inform what I put in my body
today and there's an incredible story uh
uh Pastor litz African-American guy in
Atlanta I'll never forget foret the
story he told and I might not get all
the facts right but it was just an
incredible story I was I was crying
hearing him tell me this story his
great-grandfather was a slave his
great-grandfather couldn't read or write
and after the Civil War the slaves were
freed and this guy said I don't ever
want any of my Offspring to ever have to
go through what I went through and he
wrote a family Legacy document he said
if you're in our family you were going
to get a college degree you're going to
be really careful who you marry so
you're going to have a list of the
attributes of the perfect spouse and
you're going to be a really good
business person and this guy has 300
Offspring as a result of that one
document with no divorces and a college
degree because he used Cathedral
thinking to create a legacy and this was
a illiterate slave in his
40s and I believe that those who embrace
long-term thinking when you do that you
have a crystal clear image about of
where you want to be and where you want
to go it makes today easier it makes it
easier to employ what we're talking
about Simplicity probability and
leverage when I first married my wife
she thought I was crazy but I wrote
something out and I said um it's
2070 it's April 17th we're in a log
cabin there's a fire over here we're
sipping hot chocolate our
great-grandchildren are our
great-grandchildren playing
outside and it was very clear where we
going to be 50 years from now so what
happens when we have a fight we're not
running for the exits we're Crystal
Clear where we're going and you can use
this very simple thing for anything just
like this slave did here's where my
family's going to be in 300 years here's
where my marriage is going to be in 50
years here's where my kids are going to
be and I'm going to ask you a question
what are your kids doing in the year
and most people say to me I have no idea
well my wife and I know cuz we helped
them write it
out I know this all to be true because I
know you and it makes me really
emotional uh because uh it's it's it's
got such a beauty to it about what life
is really all about and um you make it
really simple it's just question is and
I know your frustration is why don't
people just do the simple things to have
an extraordinary life and me that's the
wealth breakthrough if you want to you
know live abundantly you want to live
wealthy you want to not only generate
monetary
value but you want to enjoy the life
that goes with it I'm glad that you said
it that way because people often say you
never talk about
money this is the best kind of wealth
because by living this way you're
generating all kinds of money not only
for yourself but for Charities you
support um so it at the end of the day
it creates immense wealth it creates
wealth in people's hearts and their
families in their homes in their
businesses so thank you for having me
yeah it's a it's a it's a beautiful
purpose thanks for sharing it all and uh
I know that you've touched a lot of
people's lives right now so thank you
you're welcome to see the next episode
in the wealth breakthrough series check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there most people that
aren't doing well financially they have
zero books in their house on wealth they
have zero friends that are making the
amount of money they want to make and
they're not surrounding themselves with
an appropriate relationship when it
comes to money